link what's going on everybody this is
Tim guess RL podcast I have a special
guest for tonight this is Jack Murphy
hey everybody are you doing how do you
want to describe yourself angry angry ex
Democrat haha hangry not so angry
anymore because I left the party I'm
good
now you're happy now I'm happy having
it's great I found peace now oh there
you go yeah well I think it's funny
people often call me a Democrat still I
guess it's fair considering I've been a
big fan of Yang and Tulsi you not I'm
done I'm not I'm not going to plural
like you did you know that there's still
a ways to go for that but I'm out that's
a look that's a luxury Tim why not
you're on the sidelines this is serious
stuff I don't know I'm just your free
retina free riding free riding yeah you
thought you're saying I have to get
involved a half to go vote for Trump now
you have to do something I feel like not
doing not voting for the Democrats is is
a profound statement I get it it
definitely is about like going out there
on the limb on the limb for Trump you
know you get arrows in your back there's
like expenses of silly I know you don't
you're free be free riding on my me
being out there getting the shot up I
thought well no no I mean I think I'm
doing something I'm making that point
and I think I think the point I'm making
is actually important um whilst I've
into it but I will I need to start
recording that's important
let me yeah let me say before we get
started this is a Jack Murphy wrote a
book Democrat to deplorable former
former Democrat now on the Trump train I
guess this is a fair way to say it
absolutely
and you wrote a book about it and if you
would like to ask questions hop in the
super chat we will take questions after
the segments and then we have a bunch of
stuff we're gonna talk about and I think
we're gonna go for it cuz Jack's got a
yeah real interesting really interesting
guy yeah I known you for a little while
and I think it's been a couple years now
we've had a bunch of real interesting
conversations and the first and most
important is your book Democrats
deplorable why not let me just show it
why nine million Obama voters ditched
the Democrats and embraced Donald Trump
and you wrote that so I did I wrote I
wrote it in over 2016-2017 published in
2018 so it's been out for a couple of
years now
and the main shift behind it is that
this is a cultural phenomenon it's not a
it's not politics it's not necessarily
about tax
guts or anything like that it's about
culture it's about reason and science
it's actually it's actually about order
versus chaos and people people called
Trump the chaos candidate but that was
actually a misnomer he was the one that
we actually were supporting to take us
back to some semblance of order I think
a lot of people were starting to feel
crazy start to feel crazy when all these
issues the cultural issues that are hot
buttons today like radical feminism
intersectionality all this hyper focus
on race when you know I'm a Gen X guy I
was raised to not think about race yeah
and that's how I was you know came up my
whole life but then starting in 2012 you
know coming into 2015 all of a sudden
everybody's talking about race race race
all the time and they're all pointing
their finger at me this is just white
guy why why are you putting forget me
what did I do
yep I was an ally I was here as I was
here to help so I don't know yeah what's
it what's what's in the book and then
well we got a bunch of don't talk about
pleasure yeah yeah so the main thrust of
the book is there's three sections to it
the first part is my my my story about
how I came up in this sort of non-racial
you know don't see color don't see
gender you know I was bused across town
as part of like a desegregation scheme
so I really yes wait wasn't that called
busing wasn't it a bus thing yeah yeah I
was actually part of the busing in
Indiana I guess in the 80s yeah I was
bussed from the suburbs all the way into
the city and so like for like mix that's
I mean it's the races yeah so I was a
part of like a very radical social
experiment basically from my whole life
so whether I wanted it or not I have
kind of been thrust into this story
since the very beginning and yeah and so
the first part of the book is just sort
of laying the groundwork for somebody
like myself and I ended up working in
charter schools I ran charter schools
executive director of charter schools in
Washington DC with 99.99%
african-american population everybody
under the poverty line I was dedicated a
hundred percent dedicated to helping
minority students in the city urban
education like what could be a more
progressive cause cause than that and I
believed in it I believe in education
but eventually my race and gender became
a problem being a white man stood in my
way
getting things done I remember the very
first day I got there I started as a CFO
they gave me like a whole pamphlet on
like how black people do business
differently than white people and how I
needed to change my way of doing
business to accommodate this black
culture that I was now part of how's it
gonna make things better well you know
there's just a different way of doing
things
yeah apparently and it started with
those kind of conversations which is you
know you can I can see a place for
trying to figure out how to interact
with people that may not be of your
particular culture but now later on in
my career it got to the point where now
everything is white supremacy so like
being on time is white supremacy or your
reliance on data is white supremacy
rationality and science and math this is
all these are all now stated white
supremacy ideas I got to do it I got it
I got to jump in I got to tell you a
story
domi I don't know if I told you this one
when I would never tell you a story
about when I went to North Dakota for
the Dakota access pipeline stuff and the
fight I got into so I got it was it was
a big story I knew people who were there
so I decided to go check it out a lot of
those people like hate my guts it's
really weird like some good friends had
for years just like snapped and now
they've just think I don't know it's
weird they've gone off the rails but a
friend and I went out there we meet some
people they invite us out to lunch we go
to lunch we get pizza I've got to be in
Los Angeles in like a week and I'm in
North Dakota in the winter in a Honda
Civic mm-hmm it was that great journey
to say the least like I almost died
several times so I'm talking at this
table everyone's getting along we all
kind of agree you know I mean I'm there
and like a journalist at capacity I'm
not here to say you're right or wrong
I'm just tell me your story right and so
I told a guy I told everybody I wish I
could stay but I have to leave by
tomorrow so I can make it to LA in two
days and the guy said no dude dude you
guys that's colonial thinking man and I
said what do you mean it's colonial
thinking he goes like schedules you know
like time like you gotta be there this
time the Native Americans don't have
that you know they do things when they
need to get done that's colonial and I
was like what what does colonial
thinking mean I don't understand what
that word is supposed to represent like
and he said it was the white Europeans
who brought schedules to the rest of the
world
and I was like excuse me dude I'm part
Korean okay like we have sense of time
and scheduling we knew how to farm and
we knew when we had to do it yeah okay
we had time - it wasn't given to us and
he goes come on spy on us man we all
know that it was the white people who
brought that stuff to East Asia and I
was just like excuse me mother I was
like I'm not gonna say I got mad I
really got mad I was I was legit mad I'm
like I am sick and tired of white
supremacists like you telling me that my
culture was made by you when we did it a
thousand years before you did because he
was the white guy telling me like my
culture was built by him and that's why
like when I hear the stories like what
you're telling me yeah I'm like dude
that resonates I grew up in Chicago we
were in it was a mixed area we all got
along none of this was ever an issue
until I went to New York to Occupy Wall
Street and all of a sudden I met these
people who had segregated themselves
like jija not Occupy Wall Street they
actually had voting bloc based on race
how could you not and I remember this is
really funny I hate it I was like these
people are nuts I remember one day there
was a black dude chilling on this
planter ledge and he was arguing saying
y'all dudes are crazy and I was like I
was like what's up what do you think and
he's like do you have any idea what the
press is gonna say if they walk over
here and see segregation in this park
and I started laughing I'm like fist
pump dude I get it yeah I mean I
remember I ended up working for the
regulator for charter schools first yeah
finance I was like the CNN senior
finance director and I walk into a room
and on the whiteboard it's their vision
for the future of this organization this
government organization and on the
whiteboard is has too many white people
so they weren't even hiding it this is a
government-run agency in the district
Columbia and on the white board in their
brainstorming session about what the
future of this agency should look like
segregation there don't just don't hire
any more white people get rid of the
white people and hire nothing but POC
and people in the rainbow flag and I
absolutely have no problem with this
i-i've hired like over a hundred you
know African Americans and gay people
and whatever I trained them all I don't
care I'm looking for a performance right
but they very specifically are all
focused on what do you look like what's
between your legs and not what's between
your head and this is basically the
general thrust of the book Democrats
horrible right available on Amazon okay
you can it's a story about me and then
it's a story I interviewed fifteen
hundred people across the country we did
a national survey yeah we interviewed
people from all over I got my car and
just drove all over the East Coast went
through Pennsylvania backwater
Pennsylvania that country rather and
it's the stories of those people and
then I tie it all together at the
biggest issues the biggest issues being
globalism being the China is ascension
into the WTO what that did to
manufacturing base radical feminism
intersectionality what's going on
college campuses about how when you walk
in the door on the very first day and
orientation or like introduce yourself
by your gender yeah and here's how this
is rape culture and here's how if you
are an accuser you'll never have to
participate in any sort of hearing
against you know if a rape or whatever
and men don't have any rights etc etc so
I tie it all together and then basically
the big the big finish is talking about
how the media the academic academics the
the marketing the technology the deep
state everybody has swallowed this same
pill that's called the blue church and I
didn't coin that phrase that's Jordan
halls phrase blue church but basically
the blue chairs come to dominate
everything we can see it we can see it
today and so now people that vote for
Trump this is a insurgency it's a red
insurgents we are an emergent network
that is taken over the Republican Party
and it's much in the same way that
Bernie's people are trying to take over
the Democratic Party and you can see
parallels in both the Republican
establishment and the Democratic
establishment in trying to repel these
invaders right yeah you know we
basically the Trump phenomenon took over
the the GOP yep you know he was we were
talking about this earlier he's
basically a New York Democrat right and
he took over the Republican Party
because it was the easiest way for him
to get his agenda done Democrats would
never elect a billionaire I don't think
so at least no I don't know I think they
would
I don't know I don't even know what a
Democrat is anymore so a great foreign
to me yes so but I bring up this point
all the time if I said to you Democrat
what do you think do you think a
socialist like aoc Oh Bernie Sanders do
you think a Joe Biden warmonger
corporate Goldman Sachs element I mean
today I think a single 35 year old why
woman who can't get a date and is upset
and miserable and drinks too much wine
and has cats that's where I think of and
then cries about racism all day
everywhere misogyny all day everywhere
well there's no good men left that's
what I think of I think there were some
points in there there were a bit
hyperbolic but you're no you're but
you're not actually wrong a Pew Research
did a survey 68 percent of millennial
women are Democrats yeah and I think
it's something like 43 percent are men
meaning there is a large there's a large
portion of millennial Democratic females
who are single yeah yeah and and
millennial men are turning towards the
Republican Party and so this is the last
theme I haven't talked about in the book
is just this attack on masculinity
basically and so the Democrats are
basically the anti masculinity feminine
feminized the culture de-risk the
culture party and the Republicans are
now the party of masculine power and
masculine energy so here's here's what
freaks me out I was I was a I was a big
fan of Bernie in 2015-16 but his tune is
changed have you seen the interviews
from him back in 2015 have you seen the
news stories no you-you-you you know a
lot of his talking points overlapped
with Trump well yeah some of the
economic populist stuff definitely
absolutely yeah and they were and there
were so many articles being like Trump
and Bernie are so similar and that was
actually a threat to Bernie because
Trump is this boorish bombastic you know
arrogant dude right a lot of people love
it but Bernie was the career politician
who represented some similar things
today
Bernie's talking points are flipping
like within the month right well this
brings up a good question a decent chunk
of the nine million Democrats that voted
for
9.4 not nyeport voted for Trump a decent
chunk of them were like burned Bernie
Sanders supporters right so right I
chronicled one lady who was a Bernie
supporter delegate in a Bernie delegate
in Nevada in the caucuses and then saw
how Hillary stole Nevada from from
Bernie and then went to Philadelphia and
then saw how they treated all the Bernie
delegates yeah the whole thing and so
she was like if this yeah I'm not gonna
be a part of this and she went full
Trump and now her whole life has changed
she's like been it introduced to new
cultural ideas and new norms and new
ways of nicer people like you know and
that's the first thing she said in my
interview
yeah I couldn't believe how nice
everybody was right you know the I think
it's Andrew Breitbart quote about
walking towards the fire mmm no but
that's a good place to go if you might
be in journalism I'm not sure if it's
from him and I'm probably the freight
that it wrong but the ID it's something
like people are default liberal and
they're standing behind this wall of
fire and they're scared of it but once
you walk through it you realize on the
other side is freedom and like yeah I'm
probably ruining it yes but that's
absolutely right so to follow up on that
last point though it's like are those
Bernie people who felt you know
disenfranchised from Democratic Party in
2016 will they if bernie is the nominee
will they return to vote Democrat in
2020 I think some of them definitely
will but I think some of them are
definitely gonna stick with Trump yep
and if Bernie I know that for a fact is
for real the the nominee then I think
that they'll lose a lot of the moderate
people you know who just soar like
socialists I don't have anything to do
with that I was in Anaheim and there was
a trump rally these three guys two young
guys and an older guy got jumped
they got chased by a bunch of like
Antipa types stealing their hats
spinning on him punching them as they
ran away I interviewed the guy
afterwards and he said they were Bernie
supporters all three of them the two
young guys the older guy and he said
they were supporting Bernie because he
was a politician they felt he had the
experience in government to get the job
done but he was about trade he wanted to
you know Trump Bernie was talking about
TPP being bad about NAFTA being bad he
was talking about workers he said open
borders as a coke brothers proposal it's
bad for the workers in America they
supported that right that was back then
then when the nomination was stolen they
said Trump was the only option for them
because he was the only one talking
about how these these policies hurt them
yeah and they got attacked by these
people because now they support Trump
right but let me let me tell you
something you know what really scares me
Bernie was talking about these things in
2015 today he's fully on board the
intersectional whoa AOC I don't think
you guys listening or watching and you
PI don't know if you know this have you
ever been to Berkeley California yeah no
you go to Berkeley walk down like the
main you know Avenue just outside of the
University and you'll see on inside
every window is like the feminist
revolution fist on a poster every
business down several blocks is a sign
saying
we support these causes and we hate
Trump and I went to a bar and they had a
a poster that said Trump is you know
they called him a disparaging term I was
sitting there eating food mind my own
business
bartender seemed very nice lovely lady
and I asked her I was like what is
what's the sign mean cuz a different
language and she was like oh it's you
know we're insulting Trump and I was
like do you not like him do you hate him
and she was like I don't really care and
I was like then why do you have the sign
in your window because if we don't
they'll smash it mmm in Oakland
there was a Burger King and I saw this
in like 2014 with a sign in the window
saying please do not smash our windows
we are a family-owned franchise not a
corporate store that's the future that
awaits you when these people gain more
ground and become more powerful and
people don't people don't know this they
see they see you know these terrible
movies and the insults and cancel
culture and think oh well it's no big
deal
but they don't realize that if these
people truly got what they wanted you
would not be able to go outside unless
you put flags on your house saying yes
please we support whatever you say
please don't hurt us it's very very much
so like what they kind of did in World
War two in a certain country hmm I don't
want to say because I don't want to play
that game I don't want to draw that
parallel but you look at the photos from
Hamburg journey Germany during the g20 a
couple years ago oh yeah and there's a
there is a row of storefronts all
smashed save one you know why the one
store right in the middle wasn't smashed
up tell me they had a revolution fists
in the window there and so the the anti
faloona tix spared their store because
they bent the knee well you know Tim I
have very personal experience with
antiva right so as I'm working for these
charter schools as I'm working for the
regulator I like you I write and covered
various you know issues and I went to an
auntie for protest and Tifa versus the
alt-right Richard Spencer and all those
guys Jason Kessler they were all down
the White House so I went down there
just to check it out I stand in the
middle to take pictures right so I'm in
a picture with Jason Kessler just
happens oh yeah okay then I get into a
picture I'm in a picture with Jack with
sobic and Chelsea Manning okay
all right yep so they see me in this
picture with Chelsea Manning and Jack
with sobic and they're like who is this
guy he must be all right
so they try to identify me they find me
they
this picture with me and Jason Kessler
then they take that picture and send it
to my work and they say hey this guy's a
Nazi he is look at him he's with Yeltsin
Kessler this is a Charles Vil guy he's a
Nazi you should fire him and within 12
hours I was suspended and in two months
later I was totally fired yep
yeah and Tifa has come for me they've
stolen away my career my reputation they
boxed me they got me fired from a band
from coaching Little League okay like
yeah it went all the way through to them
taking the trying to destroy my entire
life
they even somehow we're getting in touch
with like my landlord trying to get me
evicted okay all the way down this is
the antifa trying to go after me just
because I happened to be in a picture
yep with somebody who they thought was a
bad guy while the whole time I'm
actually one of the few people in
Washington DC that's ever turned around
a school in deep in the urban inner city
and helped african-american students get
better education and it's all quantified
and you can research it and see it it's
all right there it's real data
they don't care though you don't care
it's about the tribe it's about the
ideology there's no rules I mean there's
like loose rules but the one important
rule is don't cross us so it's it's a
chaotic and destructive forest with no
mission and so when I look at what the
you know it look man I I don't think
that I've never been a person who feels
like the solution is voting against
voting for the other party who's not as
bad I just don't like it so I don't want
to do it right you know but I look at
the Democrats today they're accusing
each other of cheating you know Iowa
caucus was a disaster mayor cheat was
trending on Twitter I saw that they
liked that a lot
they booed him you can actually turn the
mic like that okay right on they booed
him in New Hampshire they're in chaos
you know and actually I think we can go
we can talk about what happen with
Pelosi because that's resulted in a lot
more Democrats saying they were done
this was the last straw for them I can't
I can't believe it
the big one of the biggest complaints
that many people have had which I've
certainly brought up is Trump does not
represent the office well in terms of
like when I think of the president as
this honorable and they haven't always
been I understand that it's not the
biggest issue to me but have they ever
actually like I mean if you think back
think back JFK
like oral sex secretary no I get it I
get it
and LBJ and think about farther and
farther back I think it's just like a
myth right no no I don't agree so that's
that's why it's not the biggest issue
for me yeah but the reason I bring it up
is then you get you know Joe Biden
called the new fad called the dude a
liar tells people go vote for somebody
else
he's certainly not doing that anything
special Elizabeth Warren just called my
pens a dog and Pelosi stands up and
shreds his speech and they want to tell
me oh but Trump is the bad guy and I'm
like you're all the same dude look I get
it man he's got a bad attitude but the
media gives him a way worse rap than he
really has yeah I just I'm ambivalent
I'm like I wouldn't pick him myself so
you know for me my attitude is they I
mean I'm one of the people who
desperately tried to say give me a
reason to stick with with the Democratic
Party yeah absolutely not I think after
Iowa I just said I am done they changed
the rules so that Bloomberg has an
easier chance of gangue on the debate
stage I couldn't believe that is such a
crock that that to me was like there's
nothing even subtle about that I know so
overt money he has money and power and
we want to use his money in power he's
on the stage he gave them over a million
dollars he gave Democratic a line to
group like 700 something and the DNC
like 300 and there it was Tulsi yang the
people I was interested in were and then
and they've already had the media coming
after them you know what I mean Tulsi
has been smear relentlessly and I was
like if I can't even support somebody so
they come in the debate stage knowing
they're not gonna win I'm not playing
I'm done I'm walking away I'm you know
that doesn't mean I'm gonna go the other
side of the aisle and go talk to it you
know I have nope but here's the thing
waters warm over here plus it's really
nice once you walk through the fire Tim
well I know I've been to the fire you
know I mean I think I think a great
example of being through the fire is the
fact that I can sit here and say like I
don't like them I want to vote for him
and you're not hitting me over the head
with a club like if or what would happen
if you went in front of aunt Yvonne said
you were considering voting for Trump
they'd scream in your face they'd hit
you it's the worst possible things and
it and even outside of like the crazy
auntie faux types you'll get like zealot
people who are gonna be alike are you a
fascist - no face it's my own family Tim
you know it's like just by this is when
I started to discover things were really
messed up in 2014 or so you know I would
start
was very active on Facebook just and not
even like as a social media person just
like my family and friends and I would
post articles that just question the
general narratives that were ongoing and
and just ask questions and live or even
2016 election like I had alienated half
my family I've been completely alienated
from my entire Democratic irish-catholic
family they want some of them won't even
talk to me anymore because I just
started challenging their notions and
then when you know whole-hog and what
went for it because I saw where we
needed to go but like it's not just the
crazy aunt Eva types it's it's filtering
down through every human interaction
that we have who your friends are who
your may is gonna be dating your love
life what it's like for your kids to be
at school if parents know that you're a
trump supporter and they're there with
your kids in the same classroom my
little daughter my six-year-old daughter
at the time she took some of my swag my
Democrats a deplorable swag did I didn't
know this took it into school for show
and tell
okay and I we live in Washington DC okay
which is like the bluest yeah place in
the hosts in the whole country and she
brings it in and they're like my daddy
wrote a book Democrats at the plural and
I was so proud and and and one of the
kids was like what's a deplorable and
they had to like shut the whole thing
down and I felt really bad for her
because she didn't know she was just
being proud but it's everywhere it's in
it's in all of your social relationships
decoding markets it's everywhere we went
to a game shop just I play Magic the
Gathering
it's card game I see I guess yeah yeah
we got a whole bunch I'm so excited
we're just we're getting it set up so we
can actually play like some nice fun
games maybe film them but this the shop
had a sign in the window that said this
is a safe space it did not feel like a
safe space because as much as I
understand what they're trying to
accomplish with that phrase it's
associated with this very violent
ideology and I've seen the physical
ramifications of those who dare oppose
it oh my god dude I walk my dog around
my neighborhood and every other house on
my street has a black lives matter sign
or another sign that says like everyone
is welcome here and it lists all the
people who are welcome but like straight
whites is I'm saying s' is as mocking in
a way that straight it doesn't say
straight whites is dudes there's nowhere
on the list right you're not welcome
oh but it's like the crazy thing about
it is you can literally just say you're
anything okay it doesn't even make it
doesn't mean right make sense but they
wouldn't know they wouldn't believe me
because yeah they cuz they can read my
mind
Tim and that of course that's what it is
it's all about them being able to read
my mind
and that and it's like impeachment like
they didn't ask a single question about
Trump's motivation with the cup [ __ ]
Hall for Ukraine they just asserted it
right and now the media reports it like
it's true well we'll save the media
stuff I wanna stick to this yeah ah
there was a segment that I did a couple
days ago Nancy Pelosi stands up shreds
Trump's speech actually I don't know if
you caught this she tried she ripped it
a little bit first yeah did you notice
that it did she had too many pages in
there serums couldn't do it well no no
no before he finished his speech she
pulls him down and she rips him a little
bit and puts him back oh so she could
just make an easy rip for a show I think
she was testing to see if she could if
she could ripped it cuz maybe it was a
stronger like maybe a plastic you know
kind of piece of paper some fancy white
house big fancy white house paper and so
she claims was because the speech was
full of lies Trump then finished the
speech before she prepared to actually
rip it and you can see it but anyway she
rips it up and I was shocked
like I was I'm sitting right over here
and we're playing we're playing the
speech and we're cracking jokes I said
to my to Adam who's you know who
normally coasts the show everything
Trump sound says is so amazing his
speech was a Matt was it was like
magical there were a few things we as
like levels left-leaning Democrat voters
were like oh I don't know about that one
but my buddy Adams like I don't
understand why they're not clapping for
you know Trump said women 70% of women
got the jobs from that from the big job
bring right not a lie they're not
standing up for it and I said Adam you
got to realize that Trump is telling you
all of the best stuff he's not gonna
criticize himself right and so at that
point there was an opening for for me
and my buddy who have always been very
Leslie and kind of dude it's like we're
skateboarding you know you know just
kind of city urban hippie kind of people
and then when it ended Pelosi stood up
and rip and are we both were just like
what did she just do the narrative
change in a second yeah no longer were
we even considering what Trump said
we'll do you think that that was
deliberate do you think that she was
smart enough to steal the news cycle
with that that's I've heard a lot of
people say no she made a serious serious
mistake
the Democrats did in general we're
watching this with my kids right and
every time Trump says something good and
the Democrats don't stand up my son goes
I hate women and then something else
happened he goes I hate black people and
somebody else I hate like those are all
gonna get cut out of context by the way
but this is this is him making fun of
the Democrats sitting down right
whenever Trump is like black
unemployment is higher lows
you know minority unemployment all-time
lows women are getting hired at all
rated and all this wonderful stuff that
you would think that they would be
totally championing they just sat there
and looked because they hate Trump
that's their policy issue it's not about
if Trump's accomplished any things don't
like the guy
Kyrsten Sinema stood up for a lot I did
but then she floated for impeachment
yeah so anyway I bring this up because
in the wake of this a bunch of people
called into c-span and it was it was
shocking I mean when I when I did the
segment on it I read the transcripts but
if you you really gotta listen to these
people
one old dude he's like I've been a
Democrat for 77 years I am done what she
did was an embarrassment to all of us
this is the president United States and
and I felt like a lot of these people
were saying what they were saying
resonated so much with me because I
always say you don't have to like Trump
but you do have to be an adult and being
an adult means sometimes the guy you
don't like wins you know if that means
that means I go I'll go vote in the next
election because it's a it's a back and
forth Bush won Obama won Clinton Reagan
you know okay so on and so forth yeah
but we're at a point now where since
2016 they won't stop
it's it's ridiculous scandals it's fake
news it's smears it's the most insane
trash yeah so like 9 million people
voted for Obama or for Trump the head
voted for Obama I think that that number
that Democrats a deplorable number is
going to increase only increase there's
not there's not once you once you go to
this side you're also not coming back
either I don't think like nobody who
decided and stood up and probably voted
for Trump after they'd been with Obama
is not gonna all of a sudden be like oh
it's time for me to go back to you know
to mayor Pete right and and I and I
really think that this number this nine
million number is gonna continue to grow
and you're seeing it now like a Jeffrey
Miller evil psych professor a very kind
of famous guy he put out a tweet the
other day saying just this very thing
like I'm they're finally losing me the
Democrats yeah and it blew
up I mean like thousands and thousands
and thousands of retweets and people are
all chiming in they're all saying the
same thing now all these people in the
threat are all saying the same thing
that Democrats have completely lost me
and it's me lost me
but I'm I'm so desperate you can see it
my face I'm like I won't vote for Trump
but it's like but you know the the
Democrats it's not the same party
obviously yeah that it was the unten or
15 years ago and it's about these new
networks these new networks that are
emerging and taking over the party and
like aoc is one of them and it's just
this it's they're finding a way to find
their power and it's through the
democratic party right and just the same
way Trump did through the through the
Republicans but there's absolutely no
way I can be a part of a caucus that has
at its core people whose main philosophy
is that straight white guys ruin the
world and we need to get rid of them
like Ikea how can I get in that but you
don't even say like that yeah I can't
get behind a party that has racism at
its core right and but let me explain
because I'm not talking about my people
I'm talking about my family and there's
a lot of people got mad at me
like I'm not like really mad like you
know down with Tim but they were like
Tim when you get mad because they're
targeting Asians like how do you feel
how do you think the you know white
people feel when they talk at white
people and I I agree I understand I
respect that I'm mostly white I come
from a mixed family everybody knows it
it's like a meme but I but I mean this
seriously when they did that lawsuit
with Harvard
yeah about Asians I'm like you realize
when they say Asian they're talking
about India they're talking about
certain parts of the Middle East they're
talking about Southeast Asia South Asia
East Asia you cannot compare someone
from Thailand to a wealthy Chinese
immigrant but that's what they're doing
and so what I say to people is if you
really want to understand the racism at
the core of this ideology I want you to
go find a 13 year old American Asian
child who was born here who grew up here
look them in the eyes and say you aren't
allowed to go to an Ivy League college
because you look too much like those
people that's what you're saying yeah I
what Asians are now gonna be a white
adjacent they already are yeah that's
exactly what it is you know I love that
phrase and it's gonna keep I love it
because like I said terrible and
disgusting and whatever but like I as in
some in summers
we should be acceleration astana
particular element because the crazier
it gets the more quickly or the faster
it does I think the more the sooner it
could be resolved right I'm hoping I
just don't think I think I don't think
matters the snowballs rolling down the
hill it's getting bigger and bigger you
couldn't stop it if you wanted to well
intersectionality has at its core like a
shrinking factor right so it just keeps
identifying all these cross-sections of
oppression and this and that before you
know it there's gonna be one person
standing in the middle saying all of you
people are against me and maybe all of
us on the outside finally can be like
this is this is pretty dumb I think it's
gonna happen in November you think so
you know I'm actually kind of worried
though because what we just saw that guy
plow that that vehicle through the
Republican tent
yeah it's gonna be a hot summer Tim oh
yeah it's gonna and it's not gonna be
because of Trump it's gonna be when they
rob Bernie Sanders I mean that again did
you follow the RNC or the DNC back in
2016 yeah of course there was there was
like no protest at the RNC nobody cared
yeah and Trump was was the one getting
nominated you know was mind blowing to
me I was at both I was covering this for
a progressive media outlet fusion it was
so woke at the RNC in almost no protest
and I'm watching at a bar across the
street because we were there to cover
the peripheral not the inside and
Trump's giving the speech and he talks
about our LGBTQ community and every
thoughts clapping and cheering that was
the Republican convention at the
Democratic convention there were
thousands of people trying to storm the
barricades and in mass protest and
police grabbing people and arresting
them that was the Democratic Party the
craziest thing to me and it's a really
good example of something happened
there's this group called juice News I
don't know if you've ever heard of him
they're a YouTube channel and they did a
show called rap news one of the clips
they made was about WikiLeaks how the
world approves of what Julian Assange
does in spreading the truth how Hillary
Clinton was a war monger how Alex Jones
was warming up the coming fascists and
about how the government was trying to
turn back the clock on freedom of speech
this was a long left wing segment
this was leftist activist media today
sounds like a trump supporter doesn't it
it's so weird
yeah and so whatever that shift was was
exemplified to me at the RNC
nc when it was the the people I knew on
the left protesting the Democrats not
the Republicans they didn't show I was
shocked I thought it was gonna be like
you know RNC was like 2007 or 2008 or
whatever when you know people that those
people in the van had like weapons and
got arrested because you know they were
protesting the Republicans no it was
Democrats I think it's gonna be similar
this time and I think maybe they'll
right after Trump wins again but here's
here's what I here's my prediction
probably gonna be wrong that's fine you
know I say that because I think this is
likely I think a lot of people are going
to be you know candidate or bust yang or
bust Biden or bust Buddha judge Arbus
Bernie or bust and their second choice
is gonna be Trump I think it's gonna so
it was nine point four million people
who went from Obama to Trump I think
it's gonna be massive this could be I
could be in a bubble I could be wrong I
think I'm right everybody thinks they do
but I think Trump is gonna win more than
people realize and it's going to send a
shock to the system for the Democrats we
saw what happened in the UK right you
see on the 13th you see what happened I
mean tell me what happened to the
biggest defeat of the left oh it's like
a hundred years yeah yeah yeah they were
able a burr setback major setback and
I'm trying to explain to my friends this
and I said imagine if a portion of Los
Angeles voted Republican like like I'm
talking like LA and they were like
that'll never happen it's impossible I'm
like there were parts of you know there
were cities that we had voted liberal
like labor left since 1929 flipped for
the Conservatives and we followed in
their footsteps with brexit brexit came
first the populist wave then Trump got
elected were on the same track a lot of
people think I'm not gonna happen I'm
not gonna pretend to be a prophet but I
there are some people that have been
then predicting a Trump slide in 2020 as
far back as 2016 and I think that I'm
probably in that camp because I really
believe that these forces are are
fundamental issues these are not surface
level issues these are deep down these
are like versions competing versions of
reality competing versions of what
science is what truth is what sex is
what gender is what men are what women
are what relationships should be like
these things these are at the core of
this separation it's even becoming less
and less about economics and healthcare
and [ __ ] it wadn't stuff it's about
being sorry
it's about being it's a it's about these
fundamental issues about who we are as
human beings and these things aren't
going to change and these these these
divisions are just gonna grow and I'm
fairly certain I'm very confident I
think that Trump is gonna win
irrespective of whichever candidate
right now comes up from the Democrats
yeah I agree and I but I think it's
gonna be a hot summer though I think
that there's gonna be a lot of action
there's gonna be a lot of quality things
to attend events to see and I hope it
doesn't get too bad but interestingly
you address it that who's gonna be the
most upset who would overreact the most
let's say Bernie wins will Bernie wins
all 2020 will Trump supporters like rage
and Washington DC setting cars on fire
and smashing glass I'm never gonna
happen probably not gonna happen is it
never know it would never happen it's
never gonna happen like for example I
went to the Richmond gun rally on
January 20th and there was about 20,000
people there and I wanted to go I
support the Second Amendment myself I
just wanted to go check it out cover it
take some pictures and see it see it
from with my own eyes it was the nicest
group of people you ever been Oh totally
right I would make a bet if Donald Trump
wins I would bet that the left would
riot yes if Bernie Sanders wins I would
bet that the left would right there's no
circumstance where out look because I've
been to these events do you know what
I've seen throughout my career going on
the ground and protests with
conservatives they sit in little chairs
and wave little American flags that's
that's that's like been the gist of it
now of course there have been you know
skirmishes with on the ground protests
between certain groups right but when it
comes to the majority of Trump
supporters they're not gonna go outside
they're not gonna go in March and smash
windows they've never done that I mean
they're law and order people also for
one right which is funny you know the
the Donald subreddit yeah got
quarantined because they were
threatening cops apparently it's
completely absurd
like the lot the blue lives matter
people are you nuts I don't know reddit
is just some universe that exists and I
have no idea
but let me never been there let me go
back to what you're saying about the
gender staffing at any stuff yeah what
I'm seeing now on the left in terms of
mainstream talking points is like
they've they've run they've they've gone
off the track right we have a left and a
right
train train track with both cards you
know slowly moving a little left little
right something happened and the cart
for the left bumped off and you started
going straight left and now you have you
know aoc saying if we don't get our act
together in 12 years you know this could
be the end of the world she was being
hyperbolic I get that I want to be fair
she wasn't literally saying the world
can end but Greta Thun Berg said we have
eight years the number keeps changing
it's getting more dramatic and even if
it wasn't their intention people on the
Democrat side picked up that rhetoric
like we have ten years left before the
world
seriously becomes you know irreversibly
damaged we can't save it and I'm like
I've always been concerned by the
environment I worked for Greenpeace and
none of us would say that kind of crazy
nonsense we would talk about the urgency
of core issues like hey there was an
accident there was an oil spill at
Deepwater Horizon
can we get some support to like you know
fight for certain regulations to make
sure this stuff hasn't happened we
weren't going around screaming the end
is nigh and now you now you have that so
that's all about motivating people and
getting people scared and giving them
like a bigger larger thing to fear
that's even bigger than people sitting
across the aisle this is it's
cataclysmic it's an ya world stuff it's
like biblical end of days kind of thing
and like they're using it in the same
way that you know people miss having the
Soviet Union right the Soviet Union was
way to keep people focused and rally us
against the common enemy yeah and
climate change or not climate change per
se but climate Cataclysm
right and yeah of the world climate
stuff that's that's all about political
motivation brainwashing building cult
you know putting people against
something that's bigger than them and
just making them scared it's about
scaring people into submission and then
they use little girls to spread the word
how difficult was it for me to ask you
to cook like fruit for you to decide to
come on this podcast with me well you
know I had to check your subscriber
count and stuff first and then I decide
it was about how many seconds it take
for you to be like oh yeah I can
definitely come out right away
do you know hard it is to do the app to
do this with people who are on the play
left I can imagine is very difficult on
with a few people over Skype and stuff
there's a few people I absolutely
respect who have come on and had
conversations with me I've had a
conversation with Sam cedar David Pakman
much respect for their willingness to
have that conversation even though we
definitely disagree but man I always
when it comes to big stories know that I
have to reach out to people on the Left
first because it takes forever
yeah and they typically say no yeah I
it's it and this is what leads me to
think Jerry you're scary because you're
you're on your unrestrained you're you
you can do you be you say exactly what
you want that's terrifying you don't
come with a style guide they don't know
exactly what you're gonna say how you're
gonna ask it they're they're on edge
they're afraid of being exposed well
it's because there is a cult and it's
and it's not that everyone on the left
is in it but they're all scared of it
yeah so I was watching Bill Maher I
think it was two weeks ago and he was
talking about Elizabeth Warren and how
she said she would have a trans teenager
yes that her you know Department of a
Secretary of Education or whatever and
he said forget the trans thing it's
insane that she would have a high
schooler pick someone in her cabinet he
turns to the democratic congresswoman
and he says you would say something
right and boy did she not want to she
was she pumped on that it did she did
she say how stupid it was
no she punted yeah she kind of
sidestepped and kind of like didn't
dress ly a dress you know what I'd say
if Bill Maher said you wouldn't I'd be
like absolutely that's nuts you know
look man first of all you're right about
the trans thing
why would Bosworth Warren give a kid the
right to you know supersede her decision
on the on a cabinet member but what does
it have to do than anything anything
anyway but this Democratic woman was I
could see it in her face and maybe just
my assumptions but I was like oh she was
worried she was worried they'll come for
her was a compliment if Warren a
Republican at one point Oh totally
yeah well she's a Republican Native
American so who is driving all this I
think I think what it is and it ties in
with what happens when you go to college
you go to college you get brainwashed
get on social media get brainwashed even
more and then you're 28 years old and
then you work a fur campaign and then
you think you know the whole world and
you're telling these candidates these
are the issues that you have to take
right and maybe they're doing Twitter
poll it is Twitter is because because I
don't know how Facebook like Bernie
Sanders is not keeping up with this kind
of social commentary in the dialogue and
whatever you know so somebody is telling
him they're these they're all getting
this horrible advice because I don't
think any of them believe anything that
they say anyway right I'd agree right so
so they Trump does right well except for
him that's why we love him right we see
we we see we almost almost
so who's tell us who's telling Elizabeth
Warren that she needs to advocate her
authority to a trans teenager who really
by all measures if is she's a trans
teenager my personal belief is that
person should be doing nothing but
attending to their personal and mental
health not being faced with having to
make a decision that's gonna affect the
entire country choosing a white house
cat that's that's abuse it's like abuse
of that little kid it's it's it's it's
meaningless right which man wire why I
don't know you know I have some ideas I
worked for a company called fusion it
was owned by ABC and Univision they
poached me from vice you know I went
join them and when they when they first
started they said we're gonna you these
posts on the wall we're non-partisan you
know and that was like the one of their
big things something happened about
seven months after I joined where they
just said you know what we've changed
our mind we're woke now and I talked to
some people and I'm gonna be very vague
here to respect some privacy but some
people involved in the company in
certain capacity said the marketing
people and the consultants told us two
important facts women are more likely to
share content angry people are more
likely to share content if we if we
create our content for angry women we
will get more traffic and make more
money that's all true yes to a certain
extent their conclusion was false but it
is true that women share more yeah it is
true that anger it's the most shares but
creating a company around the identity
of being an angry woman did not work and
the company just completely flush itself
out of existence they had a very popular
show called I think it was called drug
wars where they embedded with like
federales in Mexico and u.s. special
forces to watch
like it was it was edgy stuff they were
breaking into like cartel buildings and
like going after dealers and you watch
the arrests and then all of a sudden
they had this very popular you know
brand they had these shows that were
travel they got woke and totally went
broke and it was the marketing people
who are looking at social media data so
here's what I think happens Twitter
represents 2.2 percent of America so 80
percent of the tweets on Twitter the
active users 2.2 percent of this country
of that 1.2 percent is is the woke
Twitter audio yet the media here's
what's happening I worked in these media
companies when you go to a job they they
want to know how many followers you have
you know why you got you got 50,000
followers you're gonna get a lot of
viewers look although this almost 7,000
people watching huh we want to hire this
person so when they read an article
people will watch Twitter is is woke
insane far-left activists and so what
happens is the people who have these
these follower counts have to cater to
that to build those audiences they're
narcissistic they're sociopathic they
want to be out in front and center
everyone can see them oh I want more
followers and more followers they get
hired by these media companies write
more stories and it's basically a toilet
it is it is the water is swirling around
and they're all chasing after each other
as they sink to the bottom and
eventually get flushed out yeah so
another way of saying all that is its
money driven right absolutely yeah it's
all about money and but yeah it's
actually about unproven you know
theories about how to make money because
haven't we seen a number of lefty
publications go by the wayside over the
last couple of years who've completely
lost the plot because they spend all
their time focusing on this stuff when I
mean it's not what the thing is is what
is making money people are having
trouble figuring out what is making
money the old-line media I think is
having trouble with totally new guys we
figured it out we're figuring out how to
do it and it's figuring out and it's
it's compelling us towards our own
truths which is the best part about my
job is the best part about your job I
imagine I'm on an intellectual journey
where I get to interview people and have
them on my podcast and write books and
travel around the country talking to
people and it's it's being supported by
the people that want me to continue on
the same journey
speaking of which what is your what's
your podcast oh well podcast is Jack
Murphy live you can find that on iTunes
and Spotify everywhere else all around
we got season 2 kicking off first it's
coming up is gonna be Scott Adams coming
up next week awesome yeah so it's a good
one to get started with and you know I
also run a private community called the
liminal order and that's at liminal -
order calm and that's an all men's
community and we're all sort of focused
around the same sort of set of values
which is you know we we have none want
nothing to do with the left and we
believe in individual accountability and
we believe in taking care of ourselves
first then our family and then our
community and maybe then the nation very
Liberty minded I'd imagine very Liberty
minded individualist but yet you know
focused on family and community and it's
you know we study things that are
helping us understand this world better
today and we're also working on things
to help us become better people
meditation physical fitness
communication strategies you know
cognitive behavioral therapy stuff yeah
we're doing courses we've got PhD
professors in there teaching courses
we've got guys from the Naval Academy
teaching you know military strategy
stuff so you can better understand the
world but my point here and we can talk
about that as much as like I'd love to
well yeah is that you know they are
helping me and we're all along on this
journey together we're we're going down
our own path for truth and we're all
working together to try to find the
answers that or find the answers and to
find a way to live within this world
that is just full of conflict and hate
and racism and trying to find a way that
we can be our best selves in this
environment and so that's our pursuit of
truth and knowledge and information and
it creates media off of that and it's
funded by the people that are
participating and it's guiding it and so
that that works that's a model that
works for me
your models working for you too I just
talk about my feelings on the internet
right you you know you've monetize your
feelings yeah that's amazing
it's actually kind of a modern miracle
when you think yeah and I've done much
the same to like I tweet a lot about
family issues and fatherhood and
masculinity and such and I tweet about
my son quite a bit and those tweets do
super good super well they go viral you
know a million impressions and then
people filter through they find the book
they buy the book they listen
Podcast they joined the community and so
it's very odd actually phenomenon that
I'm able to just talk about myself and
my insights for my own life and it
turned it's turned into a career but so
so I'll go back to what you're talking
about the the media kind of dying out
these these sites I think they're going
through what I would call like the
blockbuster phenomenon like Blockbuster
Video here's the way I see it these
companies built up this business model
throughout the the to thousands of
2010's where there was a certain point
where they realized that to get the
maximum Facebook algorithm you needed to
create shock content like I mentioned
for women yeah so what started becoming
prominent we've seen this data through
LexisNexis where words like critical
race theory racism bigotry
intersectionality just skyrocketed like
crazy because these articles that
combined all of these different ideas
were more likely to get shared they
built this business model they made
millions of dollars off of monetizing
rage in in young people creating this
class of weird cultist types but now
that people are sort of breaking away
and they're over it and weak this can
bring us into another segment talking
about dating but what's happening is
those business models are decaying these
these woke leftist companies are laying
people off like crazy they're monitor
their their their businesses are just
not putting the money on anymore
meanwhile conservative many media is
skyrocketing and independent podcast and
media like mine or more importantly like
Joe Rogan being the biggest podcast he's
certainly not woke these are the things
that are dominating because he
definitely not woken up apparently over
the last couple of weeks right oh
they've been going after him like it's
it's nuts but here's the thing these
these Vox BuzzFeed they're inauthentic
they're plastic people with plastic
opinions to try and manipulate the
algorithm they accuse us of being that
way but when people listen they're like
this is two dudes having a conversation
like nobody wrote a script we're not
making things up was we as we have a
conversation right but when you watch
Vox oh they did write a script they plan
that out they mapped out their buzzwords
and their keywords to maximize that
algorithm guess what's not working
anymore people are tired of the image
right I think people can totally feel
that then yeah it's all performative yep
and you and I were talking earlier you
you think that this is coming to a
climax soon maybe
this woke this this woke phenomenon is
gonna work itself out and then we're
gonna have like an awakening do you a D
woken Inge well maybe a civil war
because if Trump wins we go we're going
there now oh yeah yeah yeah well so so
yeah let's let's let's let's call it
that there there was a guy the other day
drove his van through a Republican voter
tent I wonder why that didn't make every
headline every media there was oh we
know about what happened in Charles
Ville no one like no one in their right
mind was happy about that only the crazy
people were happy about what happened
that at that event but there was a
there's every so often there's some
leftist protesters will get in the
street and they'll block it and then
someone will idle their car slowly
moving through them right and what what
do I hear from from the BuzzFeed's from
the boxes this is just like Charles
Ville all over again and I'm like dude
okay it's not smart to do what that guy
did they put their car in idle so it's
going a mile an hour slowly pushing
towards the bank I got to go to work
right and I and I think look man if
people are protesting you gotta err on
the side of safety and don't try and you
know even inch your car through this is
my opinion I don't think he was plowing
through anybody but now we have a story
about a dude who actually rammed his car
into that voter tent and it's like
nobody talked about it the Conservatives
did the Trump supporters did and so this
is probably where you fought why you
find me on in the area I am where I'm
talking about it because it's nuts
yeah well it goes back exactly to the
same thing I was talking about the the
Richmond rally so when I was there
everybody was super cool super chill
they were african-americans there with
their guns people are taking pictures
but then the news reports man the news
report I just like this is the worst
thing ever are these people are all
violent militia military men storm
trooper in through this video what would
they do if they were black people there
they would wouldn't let that happen
can't have black people have guns the
Panthers were there right they were
there yep so it's a the media decides
what we're going to be upset by and what
we're gonna talk about so what happens
when you have millions of people who are
an indoctrinated by rage bait media
Donald Trump wins with a bigger majority
than he did in 2016 making them feel
like it's gonna be bigger yeah they're
gonna feel that they're definitely gonna
feel that because
he's I think he's going to inhere only
won by 77 thousand votes across three
states right when the allow much before
and I have a feeling that those
statesmen Michigan Pennsylvania Ohio are
gonna go even more and he brought back
the Ford deal the Ford plant 3,000 jobs
I'm like a billion dollars yeah that
he's gonna he's gonna do a lot better
yeah I could be wrong but what happens
then when you have these people who for
a decade have been indoctrinated about
the rising fascists you see these videos
where there were some Republicans at a
college I don't have you saw the viral
clip and the dude stops and starts
screaming about slitting Republican
throats and how they all have to die and
all this crazy stuff there's a lot of
these people and what happens when even
like them and their friends who are
completely indoctrinated see regular
Americans becoming fascist and what you
think they're gonna do well I think it's
interesting to think about what would
the form of a conflict look like you
know like standard you know blue and
gray on the other side of the field with
muskets that's not gonna happen ever
right but there's a new way of kind of
conducting war and it's already
happening it's you know media
manipulation and cancel culture take you
know political and social assassination
exile take capsule culture take away
your ability to conduct financial
transactions keep you know take away
your ability to earn an income you know
just completely slain are you that mean
it's happened to me I've seen it happen
bunch of people and there's just more
ways to conduct a conflict these days
than then traditional even back to World
War two do whatever it's just it's just
gonna be a different kind of conflict
actually already ongoing and we're in at
very moment yeah
we're in it and I think one of the most
important things is when you see these
stories about like running through the
the Reg voter at voter 10 I don't that
matters that much obviously it matters
to the people that guy attacked it
matters in the sense that this guy text
somebody totally respect that but I'm
talking about in terms of civil war is
the fact that there were a bunch of
there's there's a bunch of people in the
executive administer in the executive
branch that were actively plotting
against the president that work that one
guy wrote a book about it they're an
anonymous warning we're doing everything
to stop that whoa-whoa-whoa right and
then when Obama fires these people they
claim it's the heads on a pike period
that the end is here he's coming for the
families now and they exaggerate
so I think the media is gonna drive
something truly terrifying and and these
people they don't understand because
it's not the snowflake doesn't blame
itself for the Avalanche but when they
write stories claiming this is the
Friday night massacre because Trump
fired some dude they've lost it but
people they see this at home and they're
panicking they get in their van and they
plow through a Republican tent freaking
out like it's happening or they show up
at a college and they scream oh you're
all fascists and they go with clubs and
they beat people that's what I'm worried
about if these people are pushed to snap
there's an Tifa and Tifa and the
extremists are they are they really and
maybe I'm gonna catch some crap for this
but are they really like representative
of the Democratic Party are they really
no there's not but they're just like
this crazy group of people that are sort
of working on the same issue
so there's got to be some sort of
accountability from the left they have
to right this is that they have to do
something themselves but this what I
mean is worrying me when auntie fucose
out and does the stuff we see apology
pieces we see the media saying like
auntie fo the true heroes mmm when
they're doing crazy things and then you
know a good example of like what worried
me was when I was in Boston at this
condo there was a conflict there was a
right-wing side and left-wing side I got
a funny little side note for assaulting
a second but auntie pho was standing all
in front of the left-wing protesters
holding clubs and bats and crowbars and
they were wearing masks across the way
the right side were holding shields and
I was I was doing an interview with a
guy from the TSA and I pointed I was at
does that make you feel like if you look
at the right-wingers none of them are
armed through actually holding shields
your guys have weapons and he said
auntie was not with us and I said will
you tell him to leave they said no
they're here in solidarity so they are
with you well no we didn't tell him to
come are you gonna stand up to them and
tell them and take their weapons and
leave or no and he said no and I said he
start pointing out how but the other
side youth understand how dangerous they
are and these people want to protect
minorities and he pointed to a
confederate flag and I said that's one
guy with a confederate flag over the
other side and he's not even like part
of the main group and it was like it
doesn't matter they're allowing him to
be there and I turned around and it was
a Soviet flag on their side and I said
and what about your Soviet flag and he
said we don't have
and I pointed and he went oh geez I
didn't know about that yeah but so
LARPing LARPing is like an epidemic
right now I mean it feels like maybe
people are just so bored they're so
comfortable they're so cushy they have
everything that they want these you know
cuz these people that are protesting and
Tifa these guys they're not what were
their college-educated white kids from
the suburbs who are upset it used to be
when you were a kid you used to just be
like a goth or something yeah right now
you think the world is ending because
the plants on fire and now you have to
be a militant and Tifa member and go
smash things up but that's back in the
day we just used to go to raves and like
do drugs and like dance all night listen
to crazy music that was our that was our
act of rebellion back then so let's
let's combine all these things together
and I'll tell you what worries me active
members of the US government that are
publicly announcing their opposition to
the administration by any means
necessary talking about stopping the
president Trump just fired 70 of them
and I already see the comments from
people on Twitter this is the end he's
now a tyrant he's unstoppable
yeah combine that with a media that
wants that narrative because it gets
cliques so they rile everybody up and
say what would you do you they're saying
you know I'm saying people say now if
you ever wondered what you would have
done if you were in World War two
Germany you're doing it right now that's
right and then you get angry scared kids
many of whom have anxiety disorders who
had snow plow parents who cleared away
all the obstacles so they never faced a
challenge and they're frail and
terrified and words scare them and
you've got a powder keg yeah yeah victim
culture the way colleges teach people to
be emotional reasoner's rather than
rational thinkers at cetera we were
actually teaching kids to be mentally
ill in college totally and and Jonathan
hates written a fantastic book coddling
an American mind on this and his
original essay in 2015 I say in my book
too because it's it's such an important
concept we're literally teaching kids to
be mentally ill and not come out of
college with the ability to handle
conflict college is a bad idea
right and so it also teaches you then to
appeal to Authority to resolve your
minor and your minor your minor sort of
transit here incidents rather than
actually do it yourself or to take take
control of your own your own emotions
and take control of your own actions and
own up and be independent and be you
know individually minded and so you're
right you add all those things up and
especially
going back tying back to the money the
money conversation to about the clicks
and the way the media is gonna try to
how they sell advertising and how they
monetize rage and we all know that the
media loves a good war in general yep
right
so the Oh March us into Iran or into
Iraq at any any any time just to make
money and to cover that so would they be
interested in doing the same thing
within the with a civil war I don't know
man but I know that is that's but here's
what I'm thinking I'm not like a lot of
people you know they think it's
impossible but here's what I think I
think it's gonna be some kind of like
weird insurgency I don't think it's
gonna be like the country is completely
divided straight down the middle and
fighting each other I think you're gonna
see anti fast like their tactics I think
we're gonna see more consistent rioting
I think we're gonna see the Trump
administration crack down and get you
know we're gonna see more surveillance
it's gonna embolden the state and that
could lead to a cascade effect where the
increase in surveillance and Police
Authority results in more people now
becoming a legitimate response to
increasing state repression right yeah
and to the extent in Richmond or in
Virginia and other states try to keep
clamping down on the Second Amendment
this thing in Virginia got is real
serious I mean they're seriously they
are looking at you know they're trying
to pass laws where you know you can't
have a magazine any bigger than like ten
or something in your clip it's like
basically even like I said they want to
ban gun ranges yeah even like a
standard-issue police police sidearm
would become legal in Virginia so like
the those people Second Amendment people
with the guns that really believe in the
Constitution which I support 100% if it
comes down to the gun taking that's what
that is a situation an issue that people
are willing to die for and I think you
know I was watching a video about the
the actual Civil War and there needs to
be some catalyzing policy measure you
can you can call the other side evil all
day and night but it's when people
refuse to reconcile on a hard issue
about you know rights or whatever yeah
and you've got look man I
I went to the March for our life and it
was it was it was rough i I do not like
doing gotcha interviews where I might
people look stupid there something I can
do about it people were holding up signs
saying ban assault rifles and so I would
ask them hey can I ask you about your
sign and I would say I'm curious if you
were aware that
rifles were already illegal and always
have been in fact they were never legal
and they would go oh and they would
crumple it up and then be like please
stop and they would run off and I'm and
I'm like okay and so I ended up
interviewing ton of people that were
like I had no idea and I'm like oh I was
just curious
one guy argues me who are you where are
you from of course they're still legal
we just had an event and I'm like um
okay like dude I'm just a guy like
asking questions some people a few I
would say maybe like one at a ten were
actually knowledgeable about weapons but
I'm like for the most part it was a rile
people were riled up on tribe and so now
you've got the news trying to claim the
guy from NBC trying to claim that
Richmond VA was a white nationalist
rally it's insane I was there it was
that's the media trying to light the
powder keg that a man died that's why I
went and won one hand because I knew
that there were gonna be narratives
twisted about it I wanted to go see it
firsthand I wanted to take pictures I
wanted to talk to people I want to
experience with my girlfriend we just
sat there and talk to people walk around
it was it was lovely it was one
one-hundredth as rowdy as an NFL
football game yeah yeah I mean people
were so nice and polite and after you
and all this stuff and everybody filed
through the checkpoints and everything
it was super calm and I knew that there
was gonna be this spin afterwards and I
wanted to see it and I gotta tell you
after I saw the spin all the negative
race drive and stuff all the
fear-mongering it's in sends me and yet
I've seen it happen so many times but I
still have this not yet completely jaded
cynical mind where I I'm like okay I saw
reality now everyone's gonna report on
reality and then everyone will know no
then open and so it's terrifying to
think I can't be at every event or every
circumstance or every situation where I
can verify what happened on the ground
and run the counter narrative it's
terrifying to think how that adds up
stacks up multiplies goes exponential
and then basically just tears the
country apart for no damn good reason
how tall are you I am six foot four
Bradley you're a six foot four man with
a rugged beard and it was ever so cute
your naivete about about journalism the
I worked for a company that basically
told us to lie so what I was told
was I several conversations about this I
tried quitting I tried breaking my
contract because when when fusions
switched to being woke all of a sudden I
didn't fit in I have no interest like
one of the videos I did I went to
Fukushima and we like walk around like
you know did radiation testing stuff and
like talk to people and I kind of want
to talk about your weird you know
cultural stuff and so I was talking to a
higher-up one of the highest and I said
they said we want you to side with the
audience and the audience are young
progressives so my response was does
that mean if there is a factual news
event we will we won't report it because
it might offend our audience and they
said I think that's fair yes at another
meeting when we were talking about the
conventions some way it was 40 people in
the room and someone said how are we
playing this are we left right center
you know non-partisan same guy said look
our audience is young progressives and
that's who were here to side with they
don't care if the information is true
they care if the audience will like what
they hear and so what happens then when
you go to that event and it's lovely
you think the reporters gonna talk about
reality no no no listen they already
knew the narrative before they showed up
of course they already written they but
they probably called the white Nationals
and said are you going if you go we'll
film you and the guy goes I yeah I am
going and then the guy immediately goes
and buys a ticket at the last minute
being like yes I'm gonna be on you know
vice news tonight or something that's
the plan and they want the clicks so but
how many I think I think a lot obviously
it's my circle of guys my followers on
Twitter whatever Jack Murphy live at
check America live on Twitter we have I
feel like all of these we all understand
that right and even though I still get
upset by it we still understand that the
media is lying to us manipulate us for
money and friend for whatever ulterior
even bigger meta reasons yeah but our is
most of America that naive or dumb or
they don't care or they haven't thought
about it yes
so there was a poll on media that found
that Democrats overwhelmingly trust
everybody
Republicans overwhelmingly don't except
for except for Republicans but so what I
think one of the things might be
happening with say Democrat to
deplorable is people who are traditional
liberals or Democrats now getting access
to truth through social media and going
wait a minute
right right so this is this is like the
final chapter in my book actually and I
spent the whole book taking taking shots
at Marxism and and and the analysis that
he put forth on economics how it's been
adopted by the feminists but I did take
a look at it from through Marxist lens
on media and media is basically the
revolution that's happening right now
and the people that used to control the
means of media production right they're
the birds wozy and they have proletariat
or people are trying to take away the
means of media information production
and it's happened right the internet is
basically that Cataclysm a cover a
catalytic event that put the control of
information distribution into the hands
of many yep okay so in the old days it
was Walter Cronkite talking to you from
his desk telling the whole nation what
to think and feel and we have been
accustomed to a top-down information
distribution system and that's the old
way in the new way to him of course you
know this you're on the ground you're
part of the whole phenomenon as I and
myself is about the many talking to the
many and this is where the new the new
narratives come from and part of the
reason we're having this difficulty with
social cohesion is because we're social
animals that depend on an imaginary
order in our head we depend on believing
the same story as a way to feel like
we're in a tribe together and it's
imagination it's a story it's in your
head and so when there was only one guy
telling everybody what the thing can
feel was very easy to put one story into
everybody's head and you could tell if
you were on this team of somebody if you
believed the same story now we've got
many talking to many and the amount of
stories and narratives that are out
there are just in you know infinite
basically and so now there's gonna be
like an infinite number of tribes and so
we have a breakdown in social cohesion
which for a large nation of our
social cohesion is really important
we're not just living we're not living
in a small little 30 person tribe where
we have one story that we believe and we
can live together based on that you know
we're 300 some million people and the
mess up in most difficult part is that
your tribe isn't your neighbor your
tribe is actually some guy that lives in
Minnesota guys in California another guy
that lives in London and so your tribe
isn't your geographic tribe anymore so
now you got to rub shoulders every day
with people that aren't your tribe so
here's here's what I think Republicans
are gonna win they are they are affected
less by the rapid progression of media
than the left is partly due to the lack
of high-speed Internet many rural areas
that are typically conservative so that
there's a couple factors here that's one
another factor is a shared identity
under Trump Trump is the dude yes but
also nationalism so nationalism is that
that imagined order that story that
people can rally behind and that I had a
conversation on my podcast with a
gentleman named I'm getting old just the
name just jumped right out of my brain
oboe Weingard sorry bye sorry bow where
we talked about how nationalism was like
a cure for social cohesion it's like we
didn't have we weren't talking about
nationalism before but now we are
because people need it they need it they
need it because you need an identity you
need something to bring people together
and you know for me when I hear
nationalism to me it's like American
citizens it's not about race it's not
about gender it's not about you know how
long have you been in the country
it's about are you an American citizen
and do you like believe in the flag
that's it that's the day okay the
Democrats have in their caucus people
that hate America yep in the Republican
Party they're basically all like yay
America yeah okay that's almost good
enough for me right I don't want to be
on a team with people that hate America
who believe that the whole thing is a
racist oppression machine starting from
1619 it's a perfectly designed in order
to keep black people down nevermind that
was big news and never mind never mind
the fact that like Nigerian and other
African American immigrants the United
States are like the highest-earning
people that come to or that or that some
of the people I'm a great to hear away
later right like my family came here I
know I'm not coming from
like family my family came here in the
past like 150 years or something yeah
you know so so I understand the whole
immigrant argument but we weren't I
wasn't a part of that they try to rope
it in though right so I don't want to be
a part of a party that hates America so
something so nationalism you made a
really good point
I can look to the Conservatives in the
right and and identify one word can you
can you look at the Democrats and
identify a single word hate I mean I I
think that's that's obviously none of
them are saying they want to hate yeah
but there is a strong hatred of the
progressives to the establishment the
establishment of the Socialists both to
trump than to you know siz white at a
normative patriarchy it's like but but
in all seriousness the love where's the
love I know what I want to know I love
America nationalism I love America I
love all Americans go America let's take
care of America love that's love make
America great again that's love there's
love in there but but but let's do this
I think it's fair to say would it be
fair to say 100% of Trump supporters
nationalism pretty much Joe like
obviously it's 99 point something isn't
be a few people who are like
acceleration is maybe yeah if you said
the word Democrat is there a single
policy or mission or idea that brings
them all together there's nothing coming
to mind I think you know I can make some
you know makes my guess is you know
definitely intersectional race stuff
know everybody nope not even true well
right it doesn't unify the party right
yeah look at Joe Biden intersectional
doesn't play to him Medicare for all
doesn't play to him social doesn't play
to him even Warren said you reject
socialism she's a capitalist globalism
isn't it I've heard people say that it's
a it's globalist versus nationalists but
the Democrats literally don't champion
globalism they're not walking around
saying one world to new order or
something no but they do through their
policy prescription many of them do
right and and and that's one of the
things that's been scary is that going
back to the point I was making about how
Republicans have been a bit immunized
from the rapid altering of media the
reason the Democratic part in the debate
stage raised their hand to give
non-citizens taxpayer-funded health care
is because they're being rapidly
radicalized by these various social
media platforms
it's mostly Twitter where you have a
tiny pocket of Fringe activists who are
extremely loud
but who will threaten you and destroy
you if you cross the line so here's
here's my thing man
I've never been uh I'll tell you this in
2016 I was sitting across from Cassandra
Fairbanks big Trump supporter she's
still like no I don't I don't think so
not anymore yeah she's over like the
Trump yeah over like Assange and stuff
probably right yeah but but she was
super ready for Trump to win and I am I
am just so over the cheating the
cronyism of the DNC that when Trump won
I just started laughing I'm like this is
our world this is what they get it was
like comeuppance I didn't vote for the
guy but I felt a certain satisfaction in
Hillary Clinton losing after what they
did in the primaries that's not
democracy so I've always been in that
position but it's never been hard for me
to have a conversation with someone like
you or to recognize that there's a bunch
of hateful violent crazy people with
crazy ideas and crazy ideologies slowly
encroaching of the Democratic Party is
but I'll tell you this I held out I held
out hope and it's shattered with the
Iowa caucus that's cute - very nice no I
know throw that back I know I know but I
was like look man I know that Andrew
yang Tulsi Gabbard probably weren't
going to win but I hope that for various
reasons them on the debate stage would
would do something to the Democratic
Party I to a certain extent can can like
Budaj edge over his more rational
approach to certain policy ideas but
even he is not particularly moderate
where the Democrats used to be and it's
not even about that to be honest it's
about the rigging that the failure is
the inaptitude the the media smears the
lies it's just I'm out I'm done I think
actually I've been thinking about your
question as you're talking I wasn't
listening I'm thinking in my head of
course right uh if feminism I think is
something that all those candidates can
unify behind thinking like they believe
that they're feminists right they're
feminists and there's a lot that goes in
that it leads to a lot of disastrous
policy ideas it leads to you know
de-risking of the economy and it leads
to slower innovation and sciences and
Industry it leads to a million different
things at least to this
action of the nuclear family it leads to
the lower marriage rates leads to lower
fertility rates it leads to women being
in their thirties not finding a mate
because they make too much money and men
aren't going to college anymore so I
think I think feminism actually is
probably one of the more unifying
factors about all of those candidates
and I think that it's actually one of
the things that's leading to a number of
problems and let me just make this
perfectly clear I fully believe that
every woman should have all the rights
they need to have all the rights
everyone should have you should be able
to do whatever they want everything that
you know perfectly equal in terms of
under the law and equal opportunity and
all that I'm talking about radical
feminism now and sort of the long-term
effects of what happens when you stop
prioritizing family units in America and
start prioritizing individual
achievement irrespective of sort of
family which is I think what we're
starting to see and maybe we'll talk
about this a little bit later it's like
what is what does it look like in the
dating and mating markets what does it
look like for women that are thirty five
have a college degree make six years and
can't find a can't find a man let's
let's jump in it in about a minute let
me ask you a question though in terms of
the unifying factors of both parties
define feminism define feminism yeah as
you see it like the way you're looking
at what unifies the Democrats right what
does that word mean well to me feminism
means that there should be an equal
outcome for everyone so that everyone
should be able to make the same money
socialism or I say money have all the
same interest believed all the same
things have the same tendencies the same
proclivities the same psychological
makeups
there's no allowance for individuality
or differences between the genders and I
think that this is something that's
really driving a wedge between people
that see the world rationally and
understand that men are bigger and women
are smaller and men like to take risks
and women like to care take these are
broad generalizations right when you
make pop when you put them all in a
population these are real things the
Democrats deny all of that okay and it's
not just the Democrats it's in Google
it's in to our search algorithms it's in
every corporate HR department in America
where if you don't have half and a half
50/50 then you're doing something wrong
you're a bigot sir you're not bigoted
sir because there's not 50% women
men here as trash collectors and miners
okay don't say that so I have a simple
question that actually will help someone
understand what's wrong with that
ideology you're a six foot four five six
or five in the boots maybe and how much
do you weigh I'm about 245 ask I'm
asking each and every one of you
listening or watching would you rather
have six foot four two hundred and forty
four forty five pound Jack Murphy kicked
the door into a burning building where
you're crawling desperate for life or a
five-foot five hundred and thirty pounds
woman right I'm not saying that that
women can't be firefighters there are a
small faction of women who tend to be
taller and stronger and they pass a test
they do it my sister was firefighter
yeah and and and that's the truth about
equality that anyone should be allowed
the opportunity to try but there are
some roles in our society that you're
gonna want six foot four dude solving a
problem you can't be a Democrat and have
that positioned exactly exactly and
that's what my you know Tulsi tried
doing the olive branch of the publicans
they ate her alive Hillary Clinton came
after her Andrew yang has tried saying
stop complaining about Trump all day
he's not the cause of our problems they
kick they booed him from some of the
debates they won't listen to him he's
not gonna I could I couldn't tell you
told C's like platform but I can't tell
you I like her exactly like I don't I
don't I really don't know all the things
she believes in and and I like it it
would be irrational for me to know
because she's never gonna be President
she's not gonna be president at least
this cycle right but I do like her II
like her energy maybe when the Democrats
wake up from a shocking double defeat
with Donald Trump they might snap out of
it I don't know what is what is January
in Washington DC you gonna be like you
were there last time I was there
hundreds of anti fair running around
burning smashing smashing I'm from DC
man they're gonna be in my city smashing
my city up they torched an immigrant's
limousine yeah they're doing they've
sitting booths cars on fire
yeah and screaming into I went to the
deplorable right which was an
inauguration party I was there the night
that's right
that's right I think yeah I saw you that
was the night that I met a lot of people
actually for the first time and on my
way into that thing into the event we're
driving in and I'm like why are the
streets blocked off why is there so much
traffic what's going on we get there and
there's
300 people dressed in black burning
things running around naked
throwing batteries calling us Nazis and
racists and all this screaming our faces
guy it was my first time that I really
experienced the hate and the power of
that angry dark mob and man if that's
what it was the first time when they
feel like they still had hope what is
they gonna be like the second time when
the hope is extinguished and it's like
panic panic mode maybe maybe but I think
the DNC is gonna get the next big wave
yeah yeah all that rage you saw multiply
it by 10 DNC when they robbed Bernie I'm
gonna be there you're the DNC oh man
Milwaukee right yeah great town button
well I don't know look Bernie might win
he's projected to win but with Iowa with
how the Democrats play this game I mean
apparently Budaj edge is now like
starting to pull ahead in New Hampshire
I guess I think it's gonna be booty
judge at this point I think the Machine
wants and it's gonna it's gonna make it
Evan I don't know I don't know I'm not
gonna mad enough to be President I mean
I think I'm 38 I'm older than yeah yeah
38 when I was 38 I wasn't smart enough
to be President but you know you know
there is there there is a real threat to
Donald Trump with Budaj edge he's
winning rural areas over Bernie Sanders
I don't do they know he's gay yeah no
they don't
that was actually a big deal in Iowa one
viral video where a woman said whoa what
do you mean he's gay and she was like I
don't want to vote for him right all
right kind of it's kind of sad
if they do got good ideas he's gonna
save your country yeah I'm not saying
this is right or anything like I fully
supported gay marriage which is one
reason why I could leave the Democratic
Party because that issue came off the
table
right exactly how that issue came off
the table along with cannabis
legalization that came off the table
basically we're moving that way it's not
good but like I just I don't think
America is ready to watch two men kiss
each other in front of the nation as our
representative I'm not saying it's good
Ryan I'm just saying I'm just saying I
think I don't think we're ready for I
think that viral video of that woman
saying no give me back my vote
exemplifies what you're saying it's
unfortunate yeah like as far as I'm
concerned if you've got ideas I can make
the nation better then I want to hear
them how and implement them and you can
go do whatever you want with the people
love and your own private you know
business and all that stuff and yeah
that's and that's that that's that's a
really really good point you made that
Trump unfurled the LGBT flag he's the
first president to be elected supporting
gay marriage even Obama to say that to
people who are Democrats they're like no
way that's not possible you're a liar
but it's because he's not progressive
enough on the issue
he's more progressive than any other
president but by the time he became
president they'd already moved
substantially further away they don't
even remember right that they voted for
Obama who was opposed to gay marriage oh
they don't remember that it's like their
brains get scrambled and totally erased
I mean I love the fact that Trump got up
there with the flag like I said that the
the another reason people were able to
switch parties people like me that grew
up as a Democrat always wanted to be
anti-establishment always felt myself as
like sort of a punk like on the outside
it was when gay marriage was legalized
and when it looked like drugs are gonna
be decriminalized those social issues
came off the table for me and I'm like
okay now I can even consider looking at
this other this other team yeah it turns
out that T this other team is yay
America the other team is a hate America
so and combine it with a bunch of crazy
crazy people gaining more and more
ground on the Democratic side if I if
you would have told me ten years ago
that I would be proudly saying I support
Republican I would have completely
laughed in your face oh but you know
what yeah that's a good thing to
remember is that times change fast right
right so in five years ten years it
could just be we could be onto a
completely different subject completely
different players completely different
forces in in three years Trump might
press that nuclear button and you might
be like well that was a mistake
I really doubt it I think it's crazy how
people think Trump is literally gonna
destroy the world it's like so that's
what the Eric Weinstein's of the world
Eric Weinstein sees all of these issues
the same way we see them he sees the the
the feminization of the industry in you
know reducing innovation he sees the you
know anti illiberal stuff on campus he
sees all these issues the same way but
then he says but you can't let Trump
have the nukes yeah so like his R is
like risk profile is different yeah and
he sees that risk is being
whoo great I think that the chance of
anybody actually putting the button is
so small that the outcome is so bad that
it's the same it's the same expected
outcome here's here's what scares me
though what happens when you have an
eagle with a broken wing falls okay so
the the saying goes that an eagle needs
two strong wings to fly oh and right now
you have people you know like yourself
for good reason leaving the left wing
moving to the right wing and the left is
crippled and torn up and that could you
know there's the possibility that the
Republican Party comes to represent an
overwhelming majority of America like a
Reagan election that just sweeps in
everyone and that shocks the Democrats
into realizing that they've lost and a
new party kind of reforms and
restructures and grows in the next
several years with real principled
opposition to the Republicans that's
what I'm actually hoping for not because
I think Trump is the second you know the
coming of like Hitler or something
because I just think there needs to be
some alternative and some opportunity
for people who descent to have a
rational discussion about it but the
Democrats have lost detonate and that's
why I've basically said you know I was
planning on putting in the primary I was
like at first I was very much for Tulsi
and then as much as I still very very
much so respect and and and think she
would do really really well I just I've
moved more towards Andrew yang in terms
of the economic discussion over
automation I don't really agree with the
ubi stuff and now that I really think it
could win I just think that an between
Andrew Yang and Donald Trump would be
healthy and great for this country it's
not gonna happen at this point and I
don't think there's any fair game to be
played and even trying so I'm just
walking away I'm just saying no I'm not
gonna vote in the primary I'm not gonna
be involved anymore I was excited not
anymore I'm done so that leads me to I
don't know kind of losing hope and what
opportunity there may have been yeah but
I mean where are we going that's bad
right now
what do you want to change why wouldn't
you want the best economy that we've
ever had stock market the highest rates
unemployment lowest rates minority
unemployment its highest ever the most
equal flats already that we've ever had
we haven't gotten in any wars we've done
we we crushed Isis and it the Caliphate
killed the top you're right you're right
but why which end
against that why do you want to vote no
I'm not going to anymore I know but why
would you even think about that
well so am i wrong with that not that
I'm here to carry Trump's water but I'm
looking around at that today and I'm
like it's pretty good Donald Trump is
going to be sending or already did a
bunch of weapons to Saudi Arabia as well
as American soldiers for their conflict
with Yemen yeah something we shouldn't
be involved in that Congress didn't
approve of and Trump goes up in front of
the helicopter and for the president
says they're gonna pay us great it's
great for our economy there are things
about what Trump does that I on
principle I'm opposed to what do you
think a Democrat wouldn't sell arms I
know I think they would absolutely and
so you know my support for Yang was
let's get a guy in the debate stage who
can talk about ideas that are important
to America even though I know Trump's
gonna win yeah
but now what I'm saying is I I was I was
it was naive of me to think the
establishment Democrats would ever allow
me to get someone on that stage to say
those things because they didn't run a
poll for forty days before it was like
an Iowa debate so yang didn't qualify
and when he said would you mind running
you know put these polls in they said no
and it wasn't about him not qualifying
it was them literally blocking polls so
he couldn't be on that stage yeah and I
still in my naivete said I'm gonna I'm
gonna you know I'm gonna vote in this
primary just cuz I want to you know nah
I was trying to sell Lane to my son the
other day how the Democratic Party is
perhaps the least democratic institution
in America yeah isn't that ironic
they don't actually they don't actually
believe in that name I think it's funny
when you watch you know I was watching a
civil war video when they tell you what
the Democrats did in the past you know I
mean like they weren't very democratic
back then either knows the Republicans
yes and I think the party of Lincoln
don't you forget yeah yeah I think I
think for me growing up one of the
things that soured me on the Republicans
was probably religious moral
authoritarianism yes
which has gone away yes and so now
things are starting to change and I will
I will be the first to admit you know I
thought about it a lot I'm like it is
really becoming a lot harder to to be
anti-trump you know I've never been
trumped arrangment syndrome because I
think people are nuts I'm just always
been like he's not my choice he's if I'd
make make a bet it wouldn't be for him
but now with everything you mentioned
all the good things that he become he's
accomplished I'm like
I don't know you're making it a hard
argument yeah granted there's my key
issues have always been very much based
on American interventionism and foreign
policy because domecq domestic policy
for me is like you're arguing about
whether to you know run a system a
certain way and you're both saying it'll
be good I'm not an economist I'm not
gonna tell you what Trump has proved
himself yeah and that's why my point has
been what's really frustrating to me is
Nancy Pelosi tears up that speech Biden
insults people Warren insults people and
now you've got Trump who is also this
boorish braggart but he's got an economy
behind him so I'm not gonna speak for
myself I'm gonna speak for the Americans
who are like you're right Trump is all
those awful things and he's proven he
got something done while you twiddle
your thumbs and did stupid nonsense so
what do you think they're gonna go yeah
they're gonna go maybe the economy the
economy wins I think most the time and
for some reason the Democrats are on the
stage saying the economy is bad this is
the craziest thing to me how do you look
someone in the mouth who's eating a
delicious slice of pizza and tell them
to their face it's not actually
delicious I'm eating it dudes not even
it's not even pizza you're right yeah
yeah that's not even your like but I'm
holding it no it's white supremacy
that's right Donald Trump handed America
a slice of delicious pepperoni pizza
extra cheese it is dripping with sweet
greasy pepperoni fat and they're like
wow they take a bite and the Democrat
looks in their eyes and say Trump didn't
give you that and it's not pizza and it
tastes bad and your the the Gallup poll
shows that 10% of America view the
economy is the most pressing issue 90%
don't economic optimism as its highest
ever been if they go on the debate stage
and look straight look at it straight in
the eyes and say the economy is bad and
I'm like who are you lying well come on
Bert how about this Bernie Sanders we
live in a racist society from top to
bottom Elizabeth Warren racism is
getting worse every single day frankly
these are some of my main issues I just
cannot stay here and accept that I agree
I can't accept that
and I can't definitely can it's not only
that I can't support it I have to I'm
compelled to take action against it
that's that's where I've never been that
kind of person you know it's like I
won't put my weight behind it but I
don't think I'll take care of you Tim I
can
understand though why you know cuz Bill
Maher was talking with us with megyn
kelly that trump is is anti PC that's
all the matters to a lot of people
they're like yeah send in the cavalry
yes you know for me I'm just like I want
someone that I can say definitively I
respect them and I want them to
represent me and if not then I'm gonna
step back but look I'm not a crazy
person I'm not my opinion is subject to
change upon new information as much as a
lot of people don't think that's the
case my opinion on two-way changed when
I had a conversation with people about
the Constitution it was very simple I
had done a video where I said I think
certain regulations make a lot of sense
and then someone told me then can I get
regulations on your amendments and I was
like hmm
that's a good point I do like my 1
through 9 I'm not totally opposed to -
you're right yeah before we can make any
changes to these laws we need to change
the constitution I'm not going to give
up any one of my rights which means I
can't ask my mouse to do the same and my
opinion changed when someone gave me a
good argument so I'm totally I'm
probably you know and so am i I'm open
to new data
I mean I've wrote a whole book about how
you can transform after you learn some
new things and this is but you know
there's learning new things but then
also the culture the the hope the whole
discourse is just going like this it's
moving in front of us we're talking
about things we never talked about
before the direction that is going over
here though hold the Democrats left me
more than I love them I'm still the same
way I believe basically you can do
whatever you want I'll do whatever I
want and as long as we're not hurting
anybody then it should be fine that's
basically the general gist right well on
the other side you're a white man who's
benefited from privilege and oppression
privileged and because of that this is
the craziest thing to me cuz I worked
for American Eagle Airlines it's like
American Airlines regional I was in one
of our they're called zone rooms which
is basically like twelve people you know
you get or like ten people you each get
five gates when the plane comes in you
go like that you know crew of two to go
and unload the bags and all stuff there
was one dude who was it was a black dude
and we having a conversation and it was
like very very mixed environment you
know there were some Filipinos that were
immigrants there were some Latinos there
were some black people and we were
talking about political correctness for
summary
and this black dude got really angry and
he said that he was sick and tired of
being called african-american because
he's from Haiti and this PC phrasing of
what he was supposed to be didn't
respect his culture the country he came
from his nationality and and what he
believed in his expand he was like
they're just pretending to care by using
this phrase that means nothing to me but
they're trying to look at me based on
the color of my skin to tell me what I
am and they're even asking me and I was
like it's kind of crazy because that was
this was you know man this was 13 14
years ago and it to me it felt like such
a trivial thing where it's like they
used the phrase Caucasian or African
American and then someone else brought
up like Caucasians means like a Caucasus
region of like Russia it's like doesn't
even make sense and then but it was
interesting to me to hear what was
essentially at the time a very social
justice he argument that you weren't
respecting their experience and identity
but it was actually anti PC what is only
got what is white anyway I mean that's
it that's the thing like even just how
many generations occasion people are
white Irish and Italian people saw each
other as not being the same thing right
so I mean all the definitions are kind
of stupid
they still don't it's all don't I have a
friend from Ukraine and do you think a
Ukrainian person is white privilege
you'd like that it's a it's a it's an
impoverished nation you know what
compared to the United States it is very
difficult to travel to work it's not
like the worst place in the world I want
to you know say that they've got nice
places but the economy is substantially
weaker and my I was asking my friend
about if they could travel come to the
US and it's very very difficult and I
jokingly said why don't you try using
your white privilege and she said the
white privilege ends when they see the
cover of my passport right so that's
what what really frustrates me is you
know having grown up on the south side
in a very mixed area seeing police
brutality and oppression for everybody
the unifying factor was that we were all
poor people right it didn't matter
you know when when the cops kicked the
door into my apartment and we're
searching our place illegally it didn't
matter that we are a group of young
mixed-race chaps you know varying
bracket backgrounds we had one dude who
was Middle Eastern one white dude then
you have me part Korean they don't care
they were like you're poor people it's a
crime neighborhood and we heard some
dude was in here who was selling drugs
or something
and we were like you're mistaken right
it's really it's really all about class
right right all the conflicts is about
class you know I'm also from South Side
Chicago oh really 111th and Western oh
okay well since Irish oh right on Midway
yeah North yeah yeah South West Side for
me yeah
but it's all about class now it's really
and that's and that's why I was so
frustrated five years ago when all this
started happening is because it's really
it's really about class it's not about
race it's about where you are in the
system and people don't want to admit
that we have a sort of de facto caste
system in America and it was actually
getting worse and we're siphoning people
off into these information and finance
jobs and they're creating a whole new
class even separate from what you would
have considered to be the upper middle
class before right so we've lost a lot
of these jobs that used to pay 80 200
grand now you've got people they they're
only going into finance or they're going
into tech and the tech in the finance
industry is they just feed off each
other making paper about products that
don't mean anything you know how many
more ubers for dog-walking do we
possibly need which is really convenient
by the way we use the app all the time
it's amazing but it's the information
economy is creating a whole new class
and that's really what it's about it's
about a class mobility because you can't
go to Appalachia you can't read
hillbilly elegy and tell me that those
people are benefiting from white
privilege right right they're just poor
but they've actually argued that the
homeless guy sitting in is ratty old you
know jacket with holes in it holding up
a sign saying please I have nothing
they're saying but he's at white
privilege they're saying Serena Williams
the multi-millionaire is oppressed it's
it's it's insane nonsense you want you
want to know though what I think the
most privileged class in this country is
media media you know why cuz I work for
these companies and I've seen people get
paid sixty thousand dollars a year to
write about Brad Pitt's junk meanwhile I
have experience working at an airport
getting paid ten dollars an hour to lift
50,000 pounds of luggage every single
day and I took home 48 dollars after
taxes and then I walked into this
newsroom they're all like oh we're so
glad to have Tim Poole here because the
media was was praising me after Occupy
Wall Street and I started laughing when
I saw vice and I'm like I'm talking my
buddy who I still know him to there's
some there are some cool people whom
from vice who
who kind of jump ship and I was like man
what a day to enter my first job after
you know several years ago working
back-breaking you know labor I'm
exaggerating but you know like lifting
heavy heavy manual labor and I walk in
this room there's a bunch of hipsters
with flannel shirts on and thick glasses
getting paid what twenty thirty times
what I got paid to scour the internet
and write a story about how one time
they accidentally drank a bottle full of
pee while they were in downtown you know
Chicago you're literally doing the
equivalent of nothing in my eyes and
they're getting so much for it and yeah
and here's the thing about the media
class their their politics how many of
them are on the left and I'm like there
would be a revolution overnight among
the working class if they saw how much
money these urban elites got for how
little work they do some people don't
even show up to work at these companies
and no one bats an eye I'm not
exaggerating there were days at vice
where half the editorial staff would be
gone and nobody cared and they would
show up the next day and be like
whatever and they were getting salaries
admittedly vice didn't pay as much as
many companies it was like thirty to
forty thousand but I've worked I've seen
some of these newsrooms and it's like
you get the job done when you get the
job done we need you to write you know a
couple articles per day about some
stupid nonsense that gets clicks yeah
sometimes you just go home privileged
that's total privilege we don't have to
work but you know I also have sympathy
for people that work in that thought
they wanted to be journalists went to
school got a degree try to get into the
field it turns out they have to work in
some basically some click Factory
writing a bunch of baiting articles all
day about nothing and that's not that's
not what they went to school for I think
a lot of them and then I also think you
know just generally speaking young
professionals these days have it tough
out driving over here today I was
listening to NPR they're interviewing
people thinking about talking about
student loan stuff and just about how
expensive it is and how difficult it is
if you screw up just a little bit you're
getting a fault and the penalties pile
up and then it changes your whole life
trajectory yeah you know this is that's
a real issue that I think will could
could cross the aisle some sort of
healthy student loan reform or you
basically it's a university tuition
expense reforms we're like right right
right to start
my opinion is get rid of the interest
rates right now the fort well I'm sorry
the first I'm gonna do is stop the
universities from the predatory lending
schemes right they're telling kids
things they that that's complete lies to
sell in these ridiculous debt packages
then we go to people with debt we say
guess what you got to pay it back but no
more interest rates and you pay it back
only when you're actually getting paid
and it's a percentage of your income so
you don't get to walk away with the free
money but we're not gonna let accrue on
you anymore so that is to a certain
degree forgiveness due to inflation but
this idea Warren has of snapping her
fingers and taking 50k from one you know
from the taxpayer pool to give someone a
free ride college now you can't do that
because as much as the left like to say
you know there's that argument but what
about me I paid off my loans there like
that argument doesn't make sense because
you know a hold on somebody who worked
hard to pay off their loans you're now
asking for their tax money to pay for
someone else's yeah so my friend will
Chamberlain he'll tell you just take the
money freeze the endowments easy and out
because really I don't know how far you
want to get into this but the truth is
the university is a total scam and it
starts from the regulations and in
Washington you title nine is it is just
one example of where they have now sent
down from high you have to comply with
all of these new harassment regulations
and anti-racists and anti massage need
this stuff anti rape culture whatever
and if you don't we're gonna take away
your money and so then what happens they
have to go out and they have to hire all
these new people all these new
administrators all these new programs
all these offices if you look at the
chart of like tuition expense it's gone
up like this but like the number of
teachers is like this and all this whole
space is new university administrators
yeah so basically the university is just
is just funding all these people that
don't really do anything or help your
kids getting education then the jacks up
the price of tuition and then they go
out and they give you get you this free
money basically and then put the
handcuffs around your wrists also that
these administrators can get fat and
then all the while they're donating
money to the universities and building
up their endowments so the university is
using the risks around the youth's to
fund the administrators to then fatten
up their endowment
when really they should just be using
the money that people send them for the
endowment to lower the tuition to make
it possible for everyone else it's snake
will go to school it's snake oil yeah
it's and believe me I have these
conversations with my kids right my
eldest daughters 14
she's starting she's a very hyper
competitive you know high school they're
they're constantly saying if you don't
go to college you're gonna just live in
your mom's basement the rest of your
life etc etc you know she's taking AP
classes as a freshman he's gonna be
taking like always eight like busting
her butt right and my son same thing and
we're talking do you really need to go
to college and he's saying he's like dad
do I really need to go to college
anymore well you don't have to go to
college but you have to teach yourself
how to learn right you have to be some
skill you need a skill but the skill has
to be how to learn that's the first
skill you have to learn because you have
to be able to go out there and find the
information that you want now the thing
is is not everybody is gonna be able to
do that it takes a certain mindset sorne
upbringing it's certain access certain
privilege if it were has it were in
order to really learn how to teach
yourself a skill that's gonna be
marketable you've done it I've done it I
learn a new thing I learn everything
about it then I put it into practice
it's just to who we are but it's not
everybody so I say this to my kids hey
you don't have to go to college but it
doesn't mean you don't have to do
anything
like you have to learn you have to learn
how to learn on your own here's the
here's the problem I see with college
they tell you that in order to get a
good job you gotta go to college as if
like it's a guarantee when you get a
diploma you're guaranteed a job it's not
possible right and so what I what I try
telling people is all you need to
understand is that you need within
within a certain rule set rules set that
we have in law to convince mr. Jack is
sitting in front of me you're holding a
green picture of George Washington I
would like to hold that green picture
what do I have to say to you to convince
you to give it to me now there's fraud
laws you can't you can't lie but there
are reasonable things I could do in fact
one of them is can I have that dollar
right so what what happens is people you
know I thought about this when I was a
lot younger dealing with my friends who
are going to college they're they're
saying to me oh I'm gonna get this great
job and I said what will they teach you
in terms of actually acquiring assets
and money when the court what
core of what it is to trade is that
simple handing over of the dollar or you
know not swiping a card or something
they don't understand the basic economic
concepts of what trade is what it
represents what money is and so they go
to school thinking that it's a snap of
the fingers and now you have a new car
or in an apartment so I'll tell you a
funny story I may have told you guys if
you watched my segments I may have told
us a while ago recently I was hanging
out at UIC in Chicago which is you know
University of Illinois Chicago it's down
it's like almost downtown it was with a
bunch of my friends were a little bit
younger than me they were all talking
about was my friend and her friends and
they were talking about the things they
were on to school for their majors and
how much money they were gonna make one
of them looks to me and says what about
you are you in college because I was you
know two years older and I was like no
I'm not going to college and she was
like why do you want to like work at
McDonald's or something and I laughed
and I was like I'm not gonna work at
McDonald's no and I had words and fast
food anyway and she was like listen I'm
gonna graduate and I'm making $70,000 a
year and you're gonna be at Starbucks
and I laughed and I was like you really
think you'll make $70,000 a year when
you're 22 fresh out of college and she
did yeah something funny happened by the
time she had graduated I was a little
bit older I was a director at a
non-profit I wasn't making a ton of
money but I had a salaried career and I
was direct I was a director at a
fundraising branch with no college and
I'm a high school dropout guess where
she worked
starboard our bucks because when she got
out she had no real world experience and
so who's going to hire that I mean look
you get a friend you get a buddy make
connection in college you can succeed
but I would say the only real benefit to
actually go into college is networking
you don't need to go to college to
network is it networking and signaling
right yeah you get to tell the world
that you're part of this network and but
I I think that's Agena but I think it's
getting bad actually it is and any any
industry that's really involved in the
making of things that actually produces
something if you can show them that you
know how to produce it they don't write
what college you went to no it's
actually the inverse now I think college
is becoming detrimental ya walk because
they also know you come out of college
with a certain mindset in a certain
ideology and as our debt
cash requirements I got two stories for
you
the the first is I knew this dude who
worked doing web dev in Chicago and he
got paid something like 30 30 grand a
year you know at the time it was like a
decent amount of money this is a long
time ago and he told me that he applied
for this job
he had self taught how to do web design
and the company said how much money do
you want and he had no college high
school dropout and he said I don't know
I was making like 12 bucks an hour
working fast-food and they were like
how's 30 grand a year sound and he was
like what like that's so much better
and they straight up told him to his
face everyone who applied had a college
degree and they refused to accept what
we could afford because they had to pay
off their loans we wanted to hire them
we don't have the money to do it we
literally only have this in the budget
your work looks great we've seen you
have the skills we don't care if you
have a diploma he could accept a lower
salary had a higher standard of living
right right yep right so I mean I think
that but overall the college wage
premium is still a real thing and in an
information market it does it does it
does add up but the information economy
also means that you have access to all
the information yourself so go out there
and teach but really look if there's
anything that people should have learned
by this point is that dedication to a
corporation is suicide they don't care
about you and they never will no there's
no such thing as getting a job at one
place and staying there for your whole
life anymore that's not happening it's a
lottery ticket it's maybe but it doesn't
happen very often and so really the
whole thing is gonna be about how are
you going to build yourself a set of
skills that is good you're gonna find a
way to make money with and that's not
that's not about college it's everybody
everybody is gonna have to be an
entrepreneur just some degree and this
is why I think you know we've seen the
data that Gen Z is a little bit more
conservative than Millennials there's a
lot of reasons for this well I have you
have you heard this yet yeah absolutely
one of the reasons I think goes back to
the 2000s when a report came out saying
liberals weren't having kids it's a fact
conservatives were at replacement levels
and liberals were at like 1.5 you know
per family or not yeah 1.5 so you need
at least two so now we're 1314 years
and yes there are more conservative
young people I also think it's social
media it's the democratization and the
breaking up of you know it's become
easier in some sense and it's not in
some sense to be an entrepreneur I was
at VidCon a couple years ago there's big
video convention I walked past a group
of little kids and one kid goes I have
83 followers how many followers do you
have because you have 83 only have 60
and the other kids like dude I have a
hundred and they're like what
over a hundred I laughed because it was
such a silly thing to see little kids
all excited about how many followers
they had but I started thinking these
kids are talking about the basics of
building a business yes they have
customers they have clientele yes so I
saw something that was like what's the
job what would job what's your dream job
asked of kids to be an influencer Yeah
right so my son my son he hustles all
the time he's selling candy at school he
buys at wholesale he brings it to school
he sells it for a profit but through
that adventure we have I've taught him
what financial statements are what a
balance sheet is what a income statement
is marketing price anchoring customer
management customer relations discounts
seasonal flows to business you know what
a return on investment is what a
profitable profit is what's the
difference between making an investment
or make an expense he's learned all this
through selling M&Ms and sour patch kids
at school for $2 that he buys for 50
cents yeah now you know every you have
he's not allowed to do that is he he's
not a lot he got but he did get busted
once yeah and they sent him home and he
waited like two weeks and with my full
support he went back at it cuz I think I
think it's awesome black market candies
go he saw a hundred dollars a week make
him fifty no fifty dollars a week he's
13 years old it's crazy but the point is
is I am taking the time as a dad to sit
down with him and teach him what all
this stuff means we're building
spreadsheets together we're really
looking at what a business is and he's
understanding it and now there are you
can see kids can see there on tick-tock
every day took back which I love by the
way if you don't tick-tock every day and
you see these people that just blow up
into businesses yep and so you know
maybe the kids are looking for lottery
tickets in that regard but at the same
time even at 14 years old
their little favorite tik tok influencer
got all this fame and then is starting
to do product sales and product
placement and they and they go and they
live in these hype houses and they build
these little communities they're
witnessing firsthand entrepreneurial
activity that they can relate to so I'm
hoping that there's gonna be you know
sort of a new energy of independent work
and an entrepreneurial business there
but but Jack you don't understand you
just describe to me your says
heteronormative patriarchal privilege
exactly that son has a father teaching
him these things that's unfair I think
the only way for the society to be equal
is to take your child away from you so
they can grow up fatherless like all the
other kids that way they're equal right
you know you're you're being slightly
sarcastic and totally and totally joking
but it's scary when you look at things
like the APA the American Psychological
Association
oh yeah last year and basically
pathologize masculine behavior yep so
what's gonna happen in ten years if
these trends continue and you bring your
son to a doctor for stress and anxiety
but the doctors like well it's because
you're emphasizing competitive behavior
and risk-taking you need to do need to
denude him of that you need to strip him
away of his competition and his urge to
win you have to take that away from him
he can't be experiencing loss and losing
we're gonna medically castrate him but
you know why that will never happen
it's happening no no but you know well I
know I don't know but you know why it's
not gonna get to the point where we have
a society full of this there's two
there's two possibilities I don't know
maybe there's more than two Tommy to
complete collapse because people go
insane and are too frail to actually
function or more importantly the
ruthlessness of China comes and shuts us
down
well we've we if listen China's ruthless
yes they have they have now two
different kinds of camps for people who
are considered objectionable for one
reason another they have the Muslim
Uighur camps and now they have the
coronavirus camps they're doing oil
exploration and colonization in Africa
and South America they are ruthless they
are invading the South China Sea
they're they're tearing stuff up oh
they're at war with us and we are
pretending that we're not righteous why
all the way back in 1999 battle for
Seattle WTO stuff black bloc was there
and he foe was there protesting
ironically processing WTO in China
yep we let China walk into our house
steal all of our stuff make us sick and
then they're gonna kill us and take us
over that's what their whole plan it's
they're at war with us and they have
been for you know a hundred years and so
you know we're not even talking about
that and that was one of the main
reasons also that I voted for Trump too
because I knew he's the only one talking
about anyone talking about yeah yep and
it's it's real I've been covering a lot
of this stuff or at least I've been in
the periphery of a lot of like really
good journalism where you know what
China was trying to build the Nicaraguan
canal yes
compete with the Panama Canal it's like
it was one of the most environmentally
destructive projects ever proposed it
would have wiped out a major freshwater
basin in Central America didn't care
they did not care no they are they're
they're seizing land they're building
military bases they are pressing us in
the South China Sea
they are building on these atolls and
now we're hearing stories about
University professors who are secretly
receiving funding you hear about that
guy who got charged like a federal
charges Omar from our was a Harvard was
it Harvard
it was those artists it was a time
flight university was the head of like
the chemistry department maybe we're
being eaten we're being you know burned
up from the in Trump was the only one to
say China bad China bad yeah but you
know Hillary Clinton what China good
know trying to go right EVP right we
love China yeah Bernie Sanders said
China bad - he said TPP as well but now
like his he's singing a different tune
it's it's it's it's like a complete 180
yeah so you know right now you got
everyone's screaming Russia meanwhile I
think Russia is not as big a deal as
they just make it out to be they're
they're exaggerating Russian BOTS
they probably accuse you of being a
Russian 50 million times accuse me of
doing it and it's actually China yeah
that's that's engaging in a bunch of
cyber attacks in literal military
campaigns they're putting people in
concentration camps and I get this virus
outbreak they've been lying about it
it's gonna get bad and I think
regardless of whether or not the
conspiracy theory is true some people
believe that you know China has been
funding these universities and they're
these professors to spread these ideas
that would weaken America at its core
yeah I don't know if you've probably
heard that or it makes perfect sense I
don't I don't care for the conspiracies
right so the general ideas have been a
bunch of professors who have been outed
for secretly receiving funding from
China I don't care it doesn't matter
what's causing it matters that it's true
that if we end up with a bunch of
no plough babies you know these kids
whose parents have made sure there's no
obstacles in front of them they're frail
weak and scared emasculated who's going
to defend us when you know when the
u-boats come across our shores me and
the men in the liminal order an order
come join us guys come join us how many
how many people do you we've had over
170 people join us
we've got meetings in New York LA San
Fran Denver Austin Nashville DC we're
expanding where we've even got people
all over the world growth is coming
growth is happening or spreading there's
meetings everywhere it's really a
fantastic place if any of these issues
we've talked about today if any of the
stuff that we talked about today means
anything to you
and you feel like you're alone and where
you are at home or you're the only guy
at your office that thinks this way and
you can't talk to anybody about this
stuff come join us man we are probably
the nerdiest group of guys out there
because we're thinking about all the
stuff intellectually this is not a get
paid get laid kind of thing this is a
thinking man's organization and we have
personal development and an Academy
where we're teaching people personal
sovereignty how to be more discerning
how to make better choices how to embody
your ideals how to have more integrity
we're teaching people about the way that
China is engaging with us in military
strategy fourth-generation warfare we're
teaching people how to think how to
think logically how to identify truth
and we're doing it together in a
community of men to support each other
you guys do you familiar with the N AP
an AP the non-aggression principle no
it's a it's a libertarian tennant
basically you don't aggress or offend
against somebody else in terms of like
causing real physical harm or violence
or anything like that er that's us I
mean look I was curious if you oh no I'm
not familiar with that but we're I think
we I would say that we're all sort of
like evolved libertarians you know we
realized that the libertarian should be
left in sort of the classroom not in
reality but with that sort of that's
sort of the way that we believe you know
the sort of a fundamental notion we
believe in independent independence
individualism taking care of yourself
your family your community and then
maybe the nation and it's done we have
forums we have chats we have in group
meetings we have chapters all over the
country and it's about making ourselves
a better people so that we can be
for our community and this is our
response ok this is what we're doing I'm
not just out here complaining about the
left and their ideas and all these
terrible things we're actually doing
stuff and this is stuff on the ground
with real people real relationships real
community real impact real lifting of
each other up we've been there we've had
guys go through deaths miscarriages job
loss people have rallied together we
donate money we support them you know
it's a it's it's something that's
missing there's a real sense of
community ran where you care about each
other they're coming for you bro they
are come we're gonna call you every name
in the book well you know the New York
Times has already been asking questions
Politico Daily Beast's you know and I
say to all of them go away
they're gonna make stuff up hey you're
gonna keep I've already I've already
been called a Nazi a bigot it's just a
misogynistic rape advocate I think I
will be able to whether that's a right
on yeah all right well I think I think
we've sort of beat the horse to death we
did we did we did great thank you very
much for having no no dude I I'm glad
you came out do you want to mention your
your Twitter or yeah I'm gonna hit it
Jack Murphy live at Jack Murphy live on
Twitter Facebook YouTube Instagram
everywhere
the book is Democrat to deplorable why 9
million Obama voters ditch the Democrats
and embrace Donald Trump you can find
that on Amazon we're running a sale on
the Kindle right now almost all
five-star ratings for that and then of
course the liminal order which is where
you can find me every day liminal -
order calm membership is closed right
now but sign up for the waiting list
because it is going to be reopening very
soon so come on down check it out
Coleman and I I got to do a really
really hard and sincere apology for the
super chats I'm gonna I'm gonna totally
pony that up to my ineptitude we're
doing a new show Jax the very first
guess we've had and I'm ill-prepared for
how we deal with segments and the many
super chats you guys gave in so I really
do since your apology I mean I know you
guys want your questions read and you
may have noticed I kept looking over
trying to get to it but when a
conversation is good it was good and I
thought it would be inappropriate to
kind of break that flow so yeah well if
you can go back and look at him I'd be
happy to address them later we can do it
in tweets or we can do a favor I think
they'll permanently be in the stream up
on YouTube and I'll leave this one for
all viewers you know regardless of
membership you can watch it and
see those comments and then you can sum
I don't know how you I don't know you'd
address him I don't honestly I don't
know but I'm happy to forget I'm happy
to make your people happy and yeah yeah
but no I really do I really do mean it
cuz I did say we're gonna get to him and
I just wasn't able to actually do it but
you can follow me on Twitter at Tim
casts and Instagram at Tim cast
subscribe to this channel if you you
want to see more stuff like this
typically the show is you know me and my
buddy Adam we go through various news
stories and segments kind of talk about
similar things but we are planning on
bring on more guests like Jack to have
more in-depth conversations and I got I
got to be honest I think we could
actually go a lot longer but I'm also
probably going to collapse from
exhaustion so like I wake up at 6 a.m.
so I got just about 8 hours after this
to go to bed wake up and get the cycle
start it all over again but anyway
thanks for coming on man I really
appreciate it my pleasure man anytime
Tim thanks a lot thank you everybody I
appreciate it we'll see you all we're
back tomorrow at 8 p.m. on this channel
live we'll see you there
you